Well, I don't fucking know.
You want to change your recall bind, maybe?
I throw my Q.
The recall bind is your character utility option, so it's probably H.
You can hold Q, by the way, to throw it out without needing to double tap.
Oh my god, I'm live now.
Guys, I think we're fucked.
I understand.
No, no.
We're fine.
The moment I realized we're fucked was when Mac was like, Oh boy.
To me.
With zero confidence that I was the captain.
No, no, no.
I'm confident in us.
I'm not so sure about tempo.
I have so much confidence.
I'm going to show you guys who I had to pick between.
Alright, Mac.
Here's a list of other people that we could have had.
And you tell me if tempo was the best pick there.
I won't say it out loud.
But here it is.
Here's a list of people I had left.
Oh wait, I need to add you.
You're not my friend on this account.
The thing is...
Here we go.
These are the six other people I could have picked.
No boosted weapons for this one.
Hotspot landing.
If you land Draft Point or Shipyard.
I think FireDragon was the controller player.
We may have messed up.
Huh?
FireDragon doesn't even play this game.
I thought he does.
Wait, am I tweaking?
Isn't there another FireDragon?
No, FireDragon doesn't play Apex.
Am I tweaking?
He's a fucking variety player.
I had to double check every streamer to make sure.
There's someone whose name is similar to FireDragon who plays Apex.
Five months ago, he was opening my Apex account.
He was playing Pokemon cards.
Who am I thinking of?
There's another Dragon person.
Five days ago, he was playing Pokemon Colosseum.
I might be tweaking.
I was pretty sure.
Oh, wait.
Guys, we can't use Crypto this first game.
Oh, shit.
Okay, we're fucked.
We have Ash, Ballistic, Alter, Wraith, Vantage, Rampart, Caustic, and Mirage.
Play Rampart, get a charge rifle.
That's you, Tempo.
I was going to say Caustic and charge rifle, but yeah, same thing.
Okay, so what do I play?
As captain, I nominate Mac as honorary captain.
I'm giving my role to you.
Ash, Ballistic, Alter, Wraith, Vantage, Rampart, Caustic, and Mirage.
Okay, I lost track.
I already forgot what you just said.
I can see it.
It's in the announcements channel.
Okay.
Oh, God.
This is way too much information for the first game.
You play Rampart, Tempo.
Oh, thank God.
I can put walls.
Doki, do you want to be a bastard and play Vantage and just two-tap people?
Oh, yeah, yeah, I'll play Vantage.
I was literally playing Vantage two days ago.
Okay, you do that, and then I'll play...
I'll play Ash.
Yo, the map is mostly blue, right?
Why is there so many information in game one?
This is like seven paragraphs.
This is like...
Confused as shit.
This is way too many words for game one.
This is even seven...
This is eight paragraphs of information.
Okay, do I pick the brown skin?
The rainbow colored skin?
Because it's like...
I'm looking like a galaxy, bro.
Like a neon style, right?
Or do I go pink or blue?
Because it's also pink and blue.
The map.
Do you have the...
Dude, I have none of these golden thingies.
You don't have...
I have this one.
Do you have the one that's colored in paint?
Paint?
Wait, do we really need camouflage?
It's called Holika.
Is it purple, yellow, or blue?
Guys, I'm gonna put on a pink skin.
Nope, I do not.
I don't even have that one listed on here.
Holika's goaded.
That's camouflaged enough.
Blue one.
Because blue will blend into it more.
Alright, so we got...
Oh, wait.
We got rampart walls and a charge rifle.
Exactly.
That's what I was cooking up for you.
I got you, bro.
Alright.
So, if you land draft point or ship bird, you get one extra point.
But, I feel like a lot of people will land there.
Hmm.
Maybe.
Doki, what are we doing for drop spots?
I don't...
I nominated Mac as honorary captain.
You think I know?
He literally was playing rank in this map.
That drop spot channel just has a bunch of...
Everyone just trying to big dick each other and telling each other to go somewhere else.
And it's just filled with not drop spots.
How is there like 17 messages already in this?
Everyone has ADHD.
Oh my god.
Bro, I'm not processed anything.
I've been awake since 7 in the morning.
I'm not...
I'm not ready for this.
Wait, did you get a map thingy and you're X-ing out all the POIs that are taken?
Is that what Mac's doing?
You think I'm that dedicated?
Hell no.
You organized scrims.
So I thought you had it.
Temple, you organized scrims.
You should do that for us.
You picked the...
You're off work.
What do you mean you're off work?
I'm not working.
You're literally making money by streaming.
You're on work now.
Speak for yourself.
This is work time now.
No matter what, you're in a Twitch Rivals.
You get automatic money.
So you are working.
Off the clock.
That's what he said.
That's what I was trying to figure out except I just...
English.
I would...
You would what?
Oh, he muted himself.
We'll never know.
We'll never know what he said.
Oh no.
Someone in my chat was saying that they could do the...
Chrono was saying that he could do the DropSpot thingy.
But the DropSpot channel is just more than 50% filled with messages of yeah, of...
not actual DropSpots.
So it's just a pain in the ass trying to go through it all.
I said we're going Neon on E-District, Overlook on World's Edge, and Mill on Stormpoint.
Okay.
Is E-District first?
I think.
Okay, if E-District is first then um...
then we have Revival.
You know like you know the strat we should do?
We should have one of us as in Mac go like bully other teams and just drop non stop on them and then we'll just loot.
Okay.
That sounds like a good plan.
You like revive indefinitely until you don't.
Yeah, yeah.
That's literally what I did before the stream because I was trying to fucking leave the game but like they kept staying alive.
Go pick your legends now.
I got Vantage ready.
I'm on Ashe already.
Yeah.
I guarantee you someone will fuck up and they will get negative 5 points for picking the wrong thing.
That's funny.
There's like a 90% chance a team ends this entire tournament with negative points because they didn't get any and they get negative points for picking the wrong thing.
I've never seen anybody ever get negative points.
Never in my life.
Every Twitch Rivals I've done nobody has ever gotten negative.
Did they?
Have they done like you get negative points for every Twitch Rivals?
There's possibilities.
I've done so many Twitch Rivals.
Did we take a negative the last one we did?
Doki.
Who got negative?
I'm pretty sure the last thing we did we got a negative because one of us locked the wrong thing one game.
Was that with Doki?
I think it was.
No we didn't get a negative!
I'm pretty sure we did.
We did not get negative!
Was it the Apex North tournament that you perhaps put in where you got a negative?
There's no way I do not remember!
Yeah you definitely blocked that out of your memory from trauma.
Yeah I did.
Most likely.
Wait this game is strictly placement points?
What?
Wait what?
I don't know.
People in chat are...
People tweaking?
You still get points for kills right?
It's just not the extra point?
Yeah yeah you still get points for kills.
Yeah okay.
You still get points for kills it's just the boosted guns give you extra points.
Oh the boosted guns?
But there's no boosted guns for this first game.
Oh no boosted guns for this first game?
Okay.
Yep.
Wait is the lobby up yet?
Okay.
Why did no one say it?
Wait where the fuck's the lobby code?
Uh in announcements.
Oh it's an announcement?
Do we want a con creased up at Mill?
I didn't see them say they were going there.
Did they just say it?
Not the last person here.
That's all that matters.
I think we can fight them at Mill yeah?
Everyone just win their ones?
Against their counterpart?
Yeah yeah.
As long as we all win our ones right?
We can do that.
Oh wait wait wait.
Wait what game?
You said next game right?
What for what?
Mill?
Uh I don't know.
Apparently Overlook is also conned.
They said conning Overlook of all POIs.
All I said is a con is a two way thing fellas.
What isn't?
I thought you said the map.
Oh wait no that's the other maps.
What map?
Where's free?
Where is free?
I don't know.
Tempo bring up your fucking LGS maps.
I don't have a map thingy.
Bring up your LGS maps.
The moment I load into the game as a player my brain turns off.
What do you mean you're always loading?
As an observer.
Well actually my...
To be fair as an observer your brain is also off.
Don't lie to me.
So it's just always off.
You literally told me that sometimes when you're when you're watching scrims you go to sleep.
You take a nap in the middle.
Yes you did!
Guess what?
Oh no no I know I know.
If you open my stream I now have a couch right beside my computer.
Now now I don't even have to go to my room to sleep.
I can just turn around in my chair and roll over and I can fall asleep.
Guys this is the...
For those who don't know who Tempo is guys he is the official organizer for all scrims in Apex Legends.
From the Apex World Cup to the official LGS.
He is in charge of that.
And he goes to sleep after he sets it up.
Hey I wake up before it ends.
As long as you wake up before it ends.
Most of the time so just keep the lobby up until you wake up.
Sometimes Wig yells at me cause I have his stream open and if he yells loud enough I can hear it and then I wake up.
Yeah guys he gets paid to do this guys.
He gets okay actually no I don't think I think you do this as a as a hobby.
Like I'm pretty sure you get paid to manage TSM but for this it's just a hobby.
Which is a fucked up hobby to have.
Not gonna lie.
Like why would you have like you get abused by your players here all the time like at this point I feel like you enjoy that.
It's okay it's the same thing as teaching kids.
Which is what I did for like 10 years.
But it makes you drink less.
Yeah there's less alcohol involved.
Yeah I remember you told me that teaching children.
Wait we're conning Johnny's team at Neon?
Wait are we?
Johnny's at Neon?
Who's at Neon?
Johnny to back the fuck up.
I look through and people just change their shit.
It's Neon and Zap.
Oh no that's the guy I was supposed to have.
It's okay we can just go over and kill him.
It was a hard 50-50 but I ended up picking you Mac.
You got picked over Zap.
Wait how do I open the oh shit game is starting.
Wait are we conning?
Are we conning?
I don't know I don't know we're figuring stuff out.
I moved us around.
We'll just wing it and let's see.
We'll just wing it and see uh.
Two POI's.
And die.
Okay we'll see.
I couldn't type the second half.
Alright we'll see how it goes.
Do we want to just see where people are flying to and then go from there then?
I just simply.
No let's just do it.
I don't know.
Let's just do it.
Just one of us has to live at this.
As long as one of us is alive we'll be fine right?
Where's my rampart?
What do you mean where's your rampart?
Things are going so well right now.
He's locked in.
He's so locked in.
Alright.
I got my vantage in.
Do we just react drop on this?
No I thought we were going to Neon.
And we're going to go find Zap.
And uh.
Nia and Johnny?
Yeah.
Wait they got Johnny there?
Is it like Apex Johnny?
No no Johnny, Price, TV.
Whoever he is.
Who the fuck is that guy?
I thought a team with Nia, Johnny, and Zap got approved.
I was like wait.
God no.
Because Zap's not a captain.
I'm going to keep an eye out on every POI.
See if there's...
I'm going air.
Oh my god.
We know this guy isn't asleep.
Wait what happened?
Is this what scrims are like when you're not asleep?
Someone picked the wrong legend.
Minus 5 points.
No because they always get like a freebie.
There's no way.
No there should not be a freebie.
It's minus 5.
Fuck the freebies.
You get freebies too.
Yeah.
That's for a DC.
And accidentally picking the wrong thing.
Yeah.
But you get freebies in your own tournaments.
Oh it was Timmy.
Timmy picked the wrong.
Kick Timmy out.
Timmy minus 5.
Minus 5.
Minus 5 for Timmy.
He should not get privileges.
Minus 5.
What's that thing when you give someone...
Special...
Oh wait.
Special treatment.
Everybody should...
No privileges.
Minus 5.
If he doesn't get a minus 5...
He's gonna get his minus 5 back anyway.
That means his uncle works at Twitch.
Timmy you don't need this extra money.
You're already rich.
I don't need it either.
I'm just here for the vibes.
People picking?
What?
Someone said minus 10.
You just said minus 10.
Which means there's two people that...
There's two people in his own team that didn't pick a legend?
Oh wait.
Cause if he didn't pick his legend and it auto picks...
Something.
Then the other teammate would have auto picked something else.
The Bangalore and Fuse on that team.
Oh.
Minus 10.
There should be like one freebie for the entire tournament.
And Timmy used it.
No.
No freebie for anyone.
Minus points everywhere.
There's no...
You're right Chad.
With all the moving and Uber trips.
I might need this money too.
Uber trips?
Yeah I'm like moving.
But like my setup is still at my old place.
Wait you're moving with an Uber?
No as in like...
No as in my old setup.
My old setup is still at my old place.
So I have to go back and forth.
And sometimes like if I have to work really late.
I have to take an Uber back to my new place.
Because there's no public transport.
It's not that late.
I got two houses so I got an Uber back and forth.
So why haven't you moved your setup?
My lease is ending.
And it's also an apartment.
I got two houses so I got an Uber back and forth.
With my Uber prime.
Oh yeah Uber premium.
I get the Uber luxury order.
Like the ones with the luxury.
I cannot take an Uber unless it's a Tesla.
There's an Uber helicopter too.
A Tesla limousine just pulls up.
Yeah no like what was it?
The cyberpunk Tesla?
The cyber truck?
Yeah the cyber truck.
You cannot pick me up on Uber unless it's a cyber truck.
You have standards.
You're gonna stall in the middle of the road.
Someone's like dookie Teslas are death traps now.
Good I like it.
The little excitement.
The best part is you don't know if you'll survive.
That's the best part.
Where were we trying to land last time?
I don't know.
We were trying to land here right?
We were trying to land next time.
Wait.
Yo guys.
There's one person over here.
We can land here.
Who is that solo?
We can just land on that idiot.
Why did you listen to him?
No one's here.
Why wouldn't I listen to him?
This is their safety net.
We're killing their safety net.
The other two are going for kills.
Alright.
You guys can go shoot him.
I'm going to loot.
Go get him.
I threw a nade at him by mistake.
What is this zipline mechanic shit?
I don't know what's going on.
I believe in you guys.
I'm going to keep looting.
I ran into a wall.
Get a safety net.
I'm so confused.
What is a safety net?
His teammates are going to go get killed.
And this guy is their safety net.
Who's going to keep them alive?
That's what I was saying.
That's what I wanted Mac to do.
But he's going to die.
Because we landed on him.
We killed the safety.
He was meant to not die.
His teammates are going out and getting kills.
That's why he landed alone.
He's going to hide.
He was supposed to be you on crypto.
You were supposed to be...
I'm still confused.
But we got a kill.
Tempo is just...
How did you get this far in life?
I don't know.
For the guy who gathers statistics and stuff.
For the guy who is basically the lifeline of the Apex community.
What are these giant green balls that keep disappearing on my map?
That's people spawning.
Don't worry about the balls, Tempo.
Don't worry about them.
Alright, let's see.
Let me know when to scan.
Should we be roughly together?
No.
Okay.
As long as one of us is alive, we all live.
I think they're all farming kills for the kill points.
Probably.
Do I land with my attachments at least?
Oh, okay.
Mac is going to leave us so he can be our farmer.
This is why I picked you over Zap.
Mac is going to leave?
Wait, which one is Mac?
Oh, blue.
No, green.
Mac is green.
Mac is the one with the name Alverlele on top.
I'm going with blue.
Are you looking at the colors when you can see the names?
Well, because I'm looking at the minimap colors.
Looking at the minimap colors?
Oh, I just thought you were being a little special today.
I'm going to the blue area.
Oh, damn.
This is why you're not a TSM anymore.
Bro.
Oh, no.
Here's everybody.
Oh, that's fucked up.
Wait.
Guys, I need a backpack.
Wait, someone's...
No, that's me.
Carry extra ammo or alt cooldown.
Ooh, alt cooldown.
Wait, I scanned zone, so...
Are we going to zone, then?
Yeah, I guess.
I mean, we just need kills, too.
I need a backpack.
Why do you not have a...
Holy shit, you don't.
I'm getting involved.
Alright, you go get involved.
I'm just going to keep looting.
Okay, have fun.
Alright, we're the lifelines here.
Usually, it's two lifelines, but, like, only one of us is useful right now in terms of killing people.
Yeah, that's right.
Only one of us has damage.
Me.
That's true, Deadpool.
Maybe you should be the one that's going to kill people.
Yeah, that's right.
We actually shouldn't be using this.
Oh, shit!
You gotta kill it!
I knocked one.
Okay, well, come back.
Wait, does a knock equal a kill?
No.
No, I don't think so.
It's alright, the lifelines are still alive.
Welcome back.
I've returned.
Wait, doesn't this game go on forever, then?
A while, yeah.
Yeah, technically, if you play smart, yeah.
This is why I was so frustrated, because I lived for way too long when I wanted to fucking leave.
I guess I don't need to do ring console if you're doing that, Tempo.
Sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll just get the ultimate reload.
Why does it force me straight down?
I have a limit to how far I can fly.
Really?
Do you spawn with your guns?
Yeah, you spawn with everything.
It's literally three strikes.
So you have all your stuff.
And attachments and everything?
Yep.
Everything.
You get everything back.
Find me a golden treasure chest.
I'm gonna give you intel.
I have a thing here.
Found a backpack, guys.
I keep forgetting that I'm advantage.
So I can...
They're, like, sliding down, like, this way.
Down the street, you can shoot them in the back.
Alright, here you go.
Here's intel.
Whoa!
Okay.
There's a lot more people than I expected.
Ahem.
I'm running towards you.
They're coming to me now.
I'm here.
I'm heading over.
We might get run at, though.
Because there's three other teams around us.
That's fine.
Tempo will live.
Tempo, you have to live for us.
They're going up the balloon.
One more is gonna go up late.
I hit zero damage.
Oh, I'm not even looking at it.
He's 1 HP!
I don't have angle!
Oh, shit!
Did you down him off the balloon?
His controller won't be able to reach it.
Where is he down?
I heard somebody landing near us.
I got him.
Yeah, he's facing.
Does he have a charge rifle?
No.
Uh...
Let's go this way.
Let's just focus our team.
No reason.
I just want to target them.
Wait, is this someone we know?
No, I don't think so.
I'm just gonna set my sights on them.
Come here, free kills!
He just wants to cyberbully today.
Yeah, they just look bullyable.
Damn!
Look at this entire map.
Somebody's gonna push that and send that over to Twitch.
I will take that ash portal.
Get me out of here.
I don't want to stop playing, but I need help.
He's portaling for this.
He took it back, Ken.
I'm gonna take this.
I'll be back.
Oh, shit!
There's a dude right here!
Oh, wait.
I'm a fucking Rampart!
Oh!
I'm leaving!
Dude, this game is horrible!
Okay, we're fucked!
Mac, you have to die!
You have to die so you can start the respawn timer!
Okay, alright.
The game wouldn't let me in the portal!
I walked out of it and walked through it six times!
We would have seen that first.
Guys...
I'm a tree.
I mean, I'm a desk.
There's so many people here.
Why the fuck wouldn't it let me back in?
Oh my god.
Where do we go, Mac?
Where do we go?
We're chillin'.
Don't worry.
We're fine.
We had a moment where all three of us were gonna die at the same time from three different teams.
We have to have Tempo chill over here somewhere.
Build a castle there, Tempo.
Okay, Tempo, you're our lifeline.
I'm gonna be in a tree.
Okay.
Go build a castle.
You're not in zone.
I landed on a team.
I don't even know where to go!
You guys are all a mess!
There's a team above me.
Okay, let me see.
Oh, I'm in a house with a rampart.
Tempo.
Tempo, please.
Go over here, bro!
I'm trying!
Where are you going?
You're on the opposite way!
Tempo!
I need to move, but in a second.
Please!
I'm not okay right now!
See, there's a lot of people there.
Go over here.
I'm in the right hidden spot.
Why did you climb up?
Oh, there's a...
Okay, I'll climb up.
Where is the tree?
Okay.
Stay up here and just do stuff.
Alright, we'll be here together, I guess.
No, you're gonna watch over me and do stuff.
Okay, there's a...
There's one over here on the caustic.
There's two on these stairs in front of me.
There's guys here, too.
There's a caustic right here.
Oh, nice!
Caustic is getting shot at.
Did you get them?
What the fuck is this guy?
Okay, nice.
See, this is...
This is good.
You're the killer.
Behind you over there.
Oh my god, guys!
We're not the last team.
We're not last.
Somebody actually died in revival.
That's so funny.
That's mean.
Wow.
She wanted to say someone really sucks and they died 20th.
I didn't say that.
You said that.
Is that a mirage clone or is that a real people?
I said we're not last.
I literally said not last.
Because I'm happy about us getting this far.
Havoc.
Can you give me some shield cells, Mac?
Yeah.
Thank you.
That's five.
I'm one cell form.
And a bat.
I can't get up there.
I'll come up.
I'll come up from inside.
This guy's a charge rifle.
We could kill him later.
Oh, and now I can get my charge rifle.
Right here.
Thank you.
I really need... Oh, that's a lot of bats.
Wait, do we have this house to ourselves?
Yes.
Yeah, bro.
Yeah, we do.
Because we have it.
We've had it for ourselves for a while.
Oh, wait.
Is this a charge rifle?
Is that Timmy's team that got last?
Well, that's a charge rifle.
Oh, my God.
Sorry, Timmy.
Yo.
Minus ten game one and negative stuff.
Maybe you should have taken the minus ten.
You're a sniper?
Two taps people on blue now, by the way.
Yeah, yeah.
I know, but he's...
Wait, there's someone in here with us.
Someone's over here by me.
I'm down.
Help me.
Just die now.
Yeah, bleed out.
Just bleed out.
Bleed out, Tempo.
They're up here.
They're where I wanted Tempo to set up.
Tempo, Tempo, bleed out.
Bleed out, please.
Hold the button.
Okay, that's good.
Tempo, where I told you to set up, there's a whole team in there.
You rat.
You fucking rat.
I told you to set up over here before.
I went up there and then there was a full team there.
And I was like, oh, I'm dead.
I told you to do it like 20 minutes ago.
So you should have been this whole time.
We've lost our spot, Tempo.
All right, wait.
I can land on them.
Where are they?
Don't land on them.
Your body is stuck.
Fucking land on them, Tempo.
Tempo, do you build walls here so we don't get charged by full-time death?
We're going to kill these guys, Ducky.
We're going to kill them?
Fuck yeah.
I'm trying to land where you guys are peeing.
I have to bat.
Why am I just going straight down?
I broke the wall.
We bat.
And then I'm going to run up those stairs and tether them and we're going to grip this shit, okay?
Okay, I threw a name.
Jump at it.
Okay, I'm coming over.
If we die, I guess we die.
Nice, nice.
Nice, he's dead.
Oh, there's a whole team!
No, that's our teammate.
Oh, that's his teammate.
Okay, you got this.
I believe in you, Matt.
I'm resing this.
All right.
What if they res it?
Okay, I'm healing.
I'm healing.
I'm playing up.
Oh, there's another team!
There's another team!
They're not going near.
They're not going near itself.
I killed one.
I dropped down, though.
I'm medkidding.
They're all dead.
Nice.
All right.
There's a Kimbo Mozams.
Oh, there's a Caustic over there.
Tempo, come here.
Don't come to me.
There's another team.
There's a Caustic here.
Wait, I can't get out of here.
Tempo, go through zone.
Go through zone.
You'll be fine.
Trust me.
Doesn't this hurt?
Kind of, but you're fine.
It's just a little bit.
Just a little touch doesn't hurt.
I'm going in as fast as I can.
Just come up here.
This spot up here is really good.
Okay, I'm here.
We're a wall.
Build a fucking castle.
There's a team right here.
Look, we can look down at all the peasants, Tempo.
Come here.
Look.
Come here, my king.
Build walls.
Look down upon your peasants.
I'm coming over!
I'm alive!
Oh, shit.
Loot.
Nice.
I actually contributed.
Guys, bad news.
Zone bounced off.
Okay.
Wait, you were actually keeping track of that?
Enemy is respawning nearby.
You were actually paying attention?
Bad news.
Bad news bears.
We have shots here.
Tempo, give me a wall.
Tempo, please give me a wall.
Please.
I've been asked for 20 minutes.
This is exactly why I did not want to play Rampart.
We have shots on this.
Alright, charge rifle.
Tempo, stay here.
Clap some ass.
I'm gonna go fuck with the people in this building.
Wait, wait, wait.
We're clapping ass.
What if Tempo dies before we do that?
109.
Tempo won't die.
I'm heading over.
I'm providing you guys with long distance cover fire.
Okay, I am looking.
I got killed.
Yeah, I am.
I knocked one in there.
Yeah, but there's a caustic in there.
I'm up in 20.
Just keep clapping ass, Tempo.
I'll just wait here.
No pressure, Tempo, but I'm spectating you.
I need you to hit a shot.
Tempo.
Tempo, this is your gun, bro.
They're supposed to stop moving.
This is what your gun you're known for.
Yeah, I thought you were known to be...
I thought you were known for this.
Stop looking.
Performance anxiety.
I got one.
There's a team evacing next to us.
Tempo, shoot them off the evac to your right.
Up to your right.
Where are they?
Where's Ray?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
We have to get over here.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
We have to brawl, fellas.
We have to brawl.
Oh, no.
I'm moving.
I'm schmoving.
You gotta kill.
Play to me.
Okay, okay.
I'll be there in 20 years, but okay.
I'm gonna use my little bat boy to come over here.
I have no escape ability now.
One died.
One's dead in the second floor.
Come here.
Okay.
Play on me.
Oh, wait.
There's a ram shitter.
I got one, but I'm dead.
I got 40 seconds.
We have to kill this guy when he rounds this corner.
I think.
Just chill.
Chill.
Come here.
Don't go inside this way.
We're in here.
Just live.
This is all you have to do, Mac.
I'll block everything.
Wait.
Where's my timer?
10 seconds.
You gotta live for 10 seconds.
All deaths for now are final.
So I still get my res, right?
Yes, you do.
Yeah, that's right.
I got the last res.
Suck a dick.
Oh, shit.
I'm coming back full HP, bitches.
70 pump.
He's close.
Please, Mac.
He's just healed.
He's healed.
We're fine.
This is totally fine.
Don't panic.
I don't feel fine.
I'm fine.
If all deaths are final, I should land with you guys, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Get in here.
We're safe in here, Tempo.
Come on.
Please.
He needs to be our lifeline.
He needs to land away from us.
No, there's no more res in.
Oh, there's no more res in.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I'm popping an ulti-excel so we can maybe get out of here.
Okay, I have another ulti-excel so we can get it for real.
I need to look around.
There's a team out here.
Tempo, start building walls.
I knocked one.
Okay.
Come here.
We're ulting at that.
I'm fucking sending us.
Let's go, boys.
Okay.
Mark this fucking team.
All right.
I got that team.
I'm batting.
I saw you.
No.
They pulled you something.
I got one.
I got a bitch.
Can I res you?
No, no, no, no.
Just live.
You're a rat now.
You're a rat.
Rat jam.
You're rat.
You're ratty.
No.
Did you rat?
It says squad eliminated.
Are you alive?
Yo, we got a lot of kills, though.
Yeah, but I'm pretty sure other people got it.
You know what?
I'm glad we...
Yo, this team only has four kills.
Yeah, we had 15.
There's still so many people still alive.
Guys, I think, like, me panicking did not help the situation.
Wait, we got killed by Zap?
Oh, that's...
Not a good look.
That's not a good look on us.
It's okay.
We'll probably have more kill points than on this game.
That's true.
We'll probably be better than Zap.
I think we got a lot of kills.
Yeah, yeah.
Honestly, we wiped a couple...
This team only has...
The team I'm spectating only has five kills.
Yeah, I mean, I'm pretty sure we got, like...
I'm pretty sure we got, like...
We wiped three teams there, so...
No, we got 15 kills.
Wait, we got 15?
There's no fucking way.
Did we actually?
Holy shit, we're gamers.
Gamers.
Yeah.
Oh my god, we are.
Even this new team?
Even the new team I'm spectating?
They only have six kills.
Oh my god.
Yeah, they were playing zones like pussies.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, it's Vax's team.
Vax's team, you pussies.
Yeah, you pussies.
You can literally aim.
What are you doing?
Like...
You can literally be shooting people.
Yeah.
How do you even see a leaderboard in this?
If there's specific guns that you get extra points?
That's true.
How do you know if they have boosts?
I guess you have to report it.
And be like, I killed this amount of people.
Oh my god.
With this gun.
With this gun, yeah.
You guys just have to trust me.
I got 13 kills, all with the exact gun I needed.
Every single one of my kills?
Yeah, they were bonus boards.
All those 15 kills I got?
Boosted loader, right there.
Oh, what a caustic.
Oh, shit.
Oh, and he couldn't go back in.
There's still six squads still alive.
Oh my god.
How many kills does this team have?
3, 5, and 7.
So they have the same amount of kills as us.
Okay, this team shouldn't be legal.
Wait, who is this team?
Giggle, doll, and madness.
Giggle, doll, and madness?
Okay, never mind.
It's perfectly fine.
Oh my god.
Why didn't we have a caustic?
Character stinks.
Mac, everybody else has caustic.
I heard there's a bug with caustic where you can have infinite traps.
Wait, what?
What?
Yeah, because you can pick up his traps from far away now.
Oh, shit.
It's like if you pick one up from far away and throw one at the same time, it just doesn't go on cooldown.
Wait, that's fucking broken.
So why didn't we play caustic?
Why didn't we exploit it?
Why didn't we abuse it?
It sounds very appealing.
So why didn't we play it?
I don't understand.
Alright, well now we...
Okay, they're doing new...
Guys, we can't play that because they're doing new characters now, new legends now after this.
So...
Oh, this is a normal game.
This is a normal game?
What does that mean?
This is a normal game, not revival.
Yeah, the next one.
The next one is a normal game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What am I playing?
Is that how...
Who's mic did that come from?
Oh, Stumpo.
Yes, that is him.
Wait, you're roommates with Hal now?
Yep.
What am I playing in the background?
Was he second place?
Wait, didn't he get second?
Yeah, I literally heard that one.
It was second place.
No, it wasn't even...
Wait, no, team one is...
Wait, no, he won!
We had the second most kills.
They won!
What was the howling?
We were cooking.
Oh, I guess that was a good, what am I playing?
Yes, that is good.
What am I playing?
Is he giving himself a pat in the back right there?
Holy shit.
Wait, when did you...
Why does everyone have such little kills?
Because everybody is just chilling.
That's right.
Good call, Mac.
We just keep killing everyone while everyone plays scared.
What do you mean good call, Mac?
I was the one that came up with the strat!
You gave your captain spot up!
I gave the strat!
I gave my spot away!
Fuse, Horizon, Octane, Valk, Blood, Cat, Conduit, Lifeline.
Okay.
Play, Mac.
Okay, so it's not a respawn one.
Yeah, so it's a normal game.
So do we want to go support?
So we can do respawning?
No.
We just farm respawn peeking.
I'm thinking we play Fuse?
Yeah, baby!
I'm gonna go Fuse!
Okay.
And then what do I play?
Uh...
Maybe Valk?
Okay, what do I play?
Uh...
Probably Valk if we play that comp.
Okay, so what do I play?
What do you want to play?
She wants Octane.
As long as it's...
I don't know how to play Valk!
That's literally the only character I don't know how to play!
I don't play Valk because all my other teammates usually play Valk.
Okay.
I don't know how to play Valk.
Okay, okay.
Do you play Cat?
Yeah, I can play Cat.
Okay, play Cat and then...
Wait, we can't play Fuse with Cat.
Oh, that's fine.
Actually, we don't need Fuse because we're not gonna Fuse tech people.
Because Bang isn't picked.
No, no, you know what?
Do you trust me on Valk?
What is the Fuse tech?
Are you fucking...
I was like, what are we using because of Fuse?
No, but do you trust me on Valk?
Because I can try.
What?
I could learn like right now.
I'm gonna have to go ahead and say no as well.
I can literally learn right now.
She's gonna fly us and we're gonna get stuck in a mountain and then we're gonna die.
Just fucking leave!
Just detach from me!
You don't have to be attached to me!
No, no, no.
So, we'll play...
I'll play Valk and then we'll put Tempo on Lifeline.
Oh, I can be Lifeline.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then we'll put you on Catalyst.
Okay.
Alright, that sounds good.
That sounds good.
I mean like, literally the whole...
Actually, I'm gonna play Horizon instead of Valk.
What is a Lifeline blending skin?
Because it'll kill people.
Oh, okay.
Okay, but we don't have revival anymore.
Wait, Horizon just got removed.
God damn, they just removed Horizon from the list.
Why did they remove Horizon?
Oh, she has bugs in customs right now.
Oh, what kind of bugs?
You're horizontal and then the server gets sucked into the black hole.
Wait, what?
Yeah, yeah.
The server, you know what I mean?
Like the server poofs, it just vanishes.
Oh, it like destroys itself?
I thought you meant every player in the game gets sucked into the black hole.
Wait, that's fucked.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah, we were trying to play LCQ scrims.
And the whole server would just go offline.
There's just one Horizon ult and it pulls everyone in the map into one thing.
It's like a little black hole.
It just gets someone being ripped open from big mod all the way to stacks for some reason.
Yeah.
Alright, I have swapped to Lifeline.
Okay, I'll swap.
It's probably just Valk.
Wait, they gave us a new...
Oh, that is the new list, okay.
Yeah.
Okay, I think I'll just play Valk.
Okay.
And I'm Kat.
I'm Katatis, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright, where's the leaderboard?
I think you guys are cowards for not letting me play Valk.
Oh, okay.
That's okay.
I'll take being called a coward instead of dying to OOB.
Yeah.
I don't know if I...
I just don't know if I can trust you to be a pilot.
You know what I mean?
Guys, look, I can fly near and straight into a wall.
Guys, okay, we can't fly.
All I have to do is go up and you guys just detach from me.
That's all you have to do.
But what if there's a mountain in the way?
She's gonna fly right into the mountain and be like, uh oh.
Okay, if I fly into the mountain, it's your fault.
It's your fault for not guiding me better.
It's the captain's fault for not guiding me.
Not good.
So the captain should fly...
Well, the captain should tell me not to fly straight to the mountain.
You would think.
You would think everyone would know that.
I am a co-pilot.
You're the pilot.
Ah, I see.
Yeah, you already saw me panic last game.
You think I'm gonna do better on Valk?
No.
If you trust... Okay, you're right.
That was the whole argument.
Yeah, that's the whole point.
That's the whole point.
But it's because you guys don't believe in me enough.
And that's why.
I had a lot of faith in you last game, but you were panicking.
So I'm not so sure that that was the problem.
Sorry, I forgot the argument midway.
I was up since 7am.
I forgot the argument already.
You were forgetting the arguments midway the same way you're forgetting the directions midway through the flight.
You were like, alright, just don't fly into that fucking mountain.
You'll be like, hmm?
He he.
He he he.
I said they put us on a mountain.
Oopsies.
Alright, don't worry.
I believe in this new comp.
Alright, wait.
Spitfire-ry is the extra kill gun.
Oh, is it Spitfire?
I mean, Spitfire's a nice gun.
Spitfire charge rifle.
Alright.
That's the fucking worst gun combo, but okay.
Wait, can you double-ry?
No, no, it's only P20, right?
If you got a Kimbo-ry, that shit would kill so fast.
Oh yeah, I guess so.
Imagine a Kimbo-rys with hammer points.
Oh, true.
Double -ry John Wick.
You should put that in instead of P20.
Where's the leaderboard at?
Do they have a leaderboard out?
Exclamation mark now.
You're the leaderboard guy.
With you playing, no one's making it.
What the fuck?
You're right.
You should be the one making the leaderboard for us.
Oh wait, I said we were going dome, and dome is a bonus point, POI.
Oh no.
We're gonna get contested.
That's okay.
I am very petty.
If someone lands on dome on us, I am down to land on them every single game so that they get dead last.
No, just ban them from scrims.
Well, that's not enough.
That's not enough, but you will do it, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Really?
Or are you just being a little bitch?
I said in all caps of the JobSpot channel, we call dome, making it known if we are conned, we will con you the rest of this tournament.
And the rest of Twitch rivals, and for all scrims, everywhere you will be contested.
Damn.
For the rest of your lives.
Wait, hey, remember to add, nTemple's gonna ban you from scrims.
Remember to add that in.
Like, I need that in writing.
That has to be in writing.
Okay, uh...
Oh my god, are you actually writing that?
No, no, no.
I was...
I was curious...
where the scores lined up.
I like how the person below you was like, we call Neon and dome first though.
And then I just wrote, no you didn't.
No you didn't.
He just wrote, no you didn't.
Wait, what team number are we?
Eight?
Sort?
Team?
Oh, we are tied for third place with 16 points.
Wait, what?
That's crazy.
Wait, we got one placement point?
We had 15 kills.
We got 13th place, Matt.
Oh wait, did we?
Yeah, we got one placement point, what the fuck?
I didn't realize it was like that.
I think of course we got one point.
I felt like we did really good there.
We did, killing people.
If we got...
First has 22 points, and then second has 17, and then us and Hal's team has 16.
Wait, but Hal's team won first, and they still got tied with us.
Guys, we're just as good as Hal.
So it's like we got first.
Yeah, it's like we got...
It's like we got first in the World Cup!
Someone got minus five.
Get fucked.
Oh my god, it's like we're first in the World Cup, guys.
Oh, come on.
Yeah, baby.
No, this is good.
Oh, wait.
Who got minus five last game?
Timmy's team?
Yeah.
Was it minus ten?
Wait, who got minus five on this team?
I gotta add some negative fives to my chart.
He just can't break his habits of keeping track of scores, man.
I just like to negative five people.
And he said he was off the clock.
He's like, I'm off the clock.
He's like, ooh, stats right now.
Stats, stats, stats.
Who fucked up?
Who got minus five?
Team five got a minus five last time.
Who's team five?
Timmy's team.
And we killed Timmy's team, too.
Oh my god, Timmy's team is at negative four points.
Wait, wait, wait.
Who fucked up this game?
Oh my god, was it Timmy again?
Wait, was it?
Fuse, Octane, Blood.
Are those not legends?
Fuse, Octane, Blood are legends.
You know what?
That might be actually a good comp to play from dome low key.
So, who fucked up?
I'm confused.
Who fucked up?
Everything looks right.
Right?
Yeah, I'm just wondering who fucked up.
I have the rule.
You ain't gonna reinforce it.
I lied.
Wait, who fucked up?
I don't see anyone that messed up here.
We're changing comps.
I lied.
Wait, why?
You play Blood on.
I play Bloodhound.
Why are we changing comps?
Because we're gonna fuck dudes.
We're coming in.
We're playing dome.
We might be conned because of this thing.
I think we just fuck some dudes.
We're ready for the con and then we can roll out of dome.
Okay, I'm down.
But I need to know, who gets negative five?
I need to make sure they get their negative five.
It doesn't look like anybody is taking a negative here.
Oh, Watson, team fifteen.
Team fifteen?
No.
It's team fifteen.
Was it surefour?
There we go.
Was it surefour that fucked up?
Team fifteen and team five are both at negative four points right now because they only got one last game and now they both have a negative five.
Oh my god.
Negative points, suckers.
Oh my god, surefour's chat is like minus five.
XD Damn.
I'm gonna miss.
I'm gonna miss this surefour.
Team fifteen, Watson.
Damn.
Alright, I need to pick twos.
Imagine you finish the tournament, negative points.
That would be fucked.
That would be actually fucked.
That would be funny.
I'm gonna set a record at that point.
Fuse, where's fuse?
Top left.
Oh there he is, okay.
Me being first pick was scary.
You guys know how to tap strafe, right?
Yeah!
What?
Tempo?
You need to lock in, Tempo.
We're gonna go to tap strafe, pat on someone to take height, and Tempo's gonna end up in East Africa.
I'll just go straight and then run towards you guys.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, don't worry.
I believe in you, Tempo.
Don't worry, we got this.
It's okay, it's okay.
We're gonna learn today.
Tempo's gonna learn today how to tap strafe.
We're gonna teach him now.
We're going dumb.
Is there anyone right beside us?
We're getting caught?
Get ready to get banned from scrims, Zap.
Is it Zap that's conning us?
If it is, he's getting banned from scrims.
That's fucked because he killed us last game.
That's so fucked.
Purple team is landing launch site.
Do we have a team next to us?
No, we don't.
Wait, does that mean we get bonus points if we land here?
Yeah, yeah, we do.
Oh my god!
We get bonus points for not doing anything!
My gaslighting worked!
But I said, no you didn't.
Wait, someone's shooting a triple take somewhere.
Oh my god.
You saw that?
She's just like, oh.
You're right.
I didn't claim dome.
Holy shit, it worked.
What do you mean?
I didn't think it would work.
I have a purple...
I have a gold heavy mag for someone.
I need a mastiff and I need a gun shield.
Ooh, hey, look at what I got for you.
It's your birthday.
Excellent.
I have a hemlock for you.
I have one.
Yeah, we all have one.
Oh wait, it's a spitfire!
Oh, okay.
I mean, that's fine.
But should we give spitfire to...
to Mack?
Probably.
Yeah, because he's the one that's going to be farming the kills for us.
Someone take that.
Oh, there's another one here.
Oh wait, why do I have a triple take?
I thought...
Oh wait, that wasn't a nemesis.
I'm so dumb.
They could get fast pushed by launch site.
That's not good.
Yeah, they probably won't.
But like, you know.
Yeah, but they could, yeah.
Wait, did you give the spitfire to Mack yet?
No, I didn't.
Is there a spitfire anywhere?
Yeah, right here.
I'm going to drop it on top of the gun thingamajig.
I'm going to scan the thing.
I'm going to scan the ring.
Not ring, sorry, the people.
Alright.
Oh wait, you need to drop me ammo.
You don't need ammo.
I just have fuse cues.
That's all you need.
Oh wait, that's you scanning, okay.
Can you grab that assault gun?
We're all just chilling.
Oh, all the way, okay.
Wait, there's one guy, wait.
No, yeah, there's these two teams here.
They're fighting each other.
Ping me a charge rifle.
I think we looted everything.
Alright Mack, what are we going to do?
I need shotgun ammo.
Craft some bats.
Yeah, I can give you some.
I have two shield cells, what the fuck, I am broke.
Go craft a bat.
Yay, how many points do we get, Mack?
We're landing here.
One.
Yeah.
It's just a freebie.
Wait, do you already have your mastiff?
Yeah, I need a shotgun bolt though.
No, I don't have that.
Is there a shotty bolt back there?
Nope, I didn't see any.
Let's get moving out of here.
Yo, I just picked up a 4-10.
Whoa, that's for your future.
But I don't have a charge rifle.
There's a charge rifle right here.
Oh, yes.
4-10 charge rifle.
I'm going to go grab this.
Make people angry.
Should I get Raven's Blessing or Odin's Glare?
The scan.
The double scan duration.
Okay, Odin's Glare.
Alright.
I just noticed different people like different things.
I'm in this building, I don't see a charge rifle.
It's in there somewhere.
It's not very helpful.
In this building?
Yeah, can you also hit the rune console?
Again?
It should be in here.
He never hit it.
It was in the other one.
Just hit the rune console.
Yeah, we shouldn't waste your time.
We're chilling.
Playing slow.
Don't pull to us.
I don't think it's going to pull to us.
Okay, we're good.
We're next to it though.
Yeah, yeah.
We should start moving back here.
Alright, I'm heading over.
Where's the charge rifle?
You'll never have one, I guess.
It was in here.
Are you sure?
Did no one want this gold heavy?
Oh, so he's just blind.
There we go.
Did no one want that gold heavy?
No, I don't need it.
Grab your charge rifle and then we gotta start fucking schmoving, gentlemen.
Oh, I'm rich, bitch.
I'm heading over.
I don't think there's anyone back here.
Alright, I'm heading over.
I'm heading from the back.
A guy just jumped off the height there.
That's scary.
Nah, we're chilling.
He just zipped back up.
You know, things could get a little sketchy.
Yeah, because we're sort of like a killing comp.
But I don't think we're going to be doing much killing.
We might, we might.
Alright.
We need more nades.
Oh, we can listen to Hal's comms, too.
Can you open your door, Tempo?
Both doors are open.
Let's see what Hugh thinks right now.
Alright, we're going to just negative rotate, actually.
We're just going to go back, hit that UAV, and then we'll get ring three.
Because there's people at that back building.
Okay.
It's just dying immediately.
Oh wait, there's another... Oh wait, never mind.
No, I just didn't know why.
Right, right, right.
Ooh, you can open that bin for us.
That's what I just said.
No, we just went over that.
We just went over this.
One second ago.
She's in La La Land.
Sorry, I tuned you guys out and tuned back in.
It's like a radio.
There's a team crafting here.
We can maybe kill them.
A team is crafting?
Yeah, they're right here.
In the middle, free kill!
I'm trying to...
Are they?
He's in the middle, right here.
I'm hitting him.
Flash, flash!
Cracked one!
He's running.
I'm shield selling.
They're going inside.
No!
We can kill this.
Okay.
I'm walking up on the left.
Walking up right.
Going middle.
They're not there, but not close to me.
I don't know which direction they are.
One's on my side.
One's on roof.
On roof!
Help!
I'm heading over.
I'm on roof now.
There's another guy back here.
Take the kill and go southwest.
I might be dead.
I'm getting shot at.
I'm batting.
Can we walk away this way?
I'm batting right now.
I'm heading back now.
I'm shooting for you.
You're good.
I'm batting again.
I got shot from...
Is that a different team?
I got shot from back.
Can you crawl up here?
I might be dead.
I might be dead, boys.
I'm slowly dying.
I don't see them.
I'm going to rest.
I am the beta test.
The scouter.
You're okay.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Literally at the edge.
I'm watching.
Just pop a fucking...
Take my armor.
Are you...
I am not having a good day.
We're going to go this way, okay?
We have to go this way.
Oh, wait.
I have no...
Shield meds.
I can drop you some if I live.
Come here.
We're going to pad over here.
Drop some.
Slide into it.
Tempo, please live because I gave you my shields.
Oh, I just died.
Are you resable?
I'm safe now, yeah.
Okay, I'll get him.
Just keep an eye on dome, Doki.
I am looking at dome.
Oh, I'm going to die to this fucking fuse cube bullshit.
Nope, I'm good.
I'm going to look for you guys.
I'm going to drop you my armor, Tempo.
Okay.
They're looking at me, I think.
Take my armor.
Okay, goodbye.
We have to hide, Doki.
Okay.
I don't...
You have to hide.
I got shot from this side.
I'm glad we got that one point though.
Goodbye.
You got this, I believe.
I believe.
They're getting ran at, but then they're running at you too.
No!
Hey guys, not last though.
Nice try, nice try.
Damn.
I lost my gold charge rifle.
Bro, everybody... What the fuck?
That was two catalyst ults.
I think we might need to play defensive on the normal games.
Oh my god.
Wait, what was that beep... Oh, the bins.
Yeah, it's the bins.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe we should have just killed that team in the building.
Did we get thirded there?
Yeah, there was another team on the east side of the dome that I shot at.
Yeah.
There was three teams.
There was the team inside dome, the team inside launch, and then the team that walked out from that hill.
Oh, I see.
Hey, we got two points though, at least.
Wait, did we get two kills?
No, we got one kill, and then we got the free point for landing in dome.
Oh, the free point.
I was like, where did we get two?
The free point.
It goes far.
What the fuck is good kitten?
Ooh, ooh.
You see that?
Are you guys spectating the same people I am?
No.
I got Emi.
Design.
I have... And someone else.
Perfect lioness.
And... I don't know.
Wait, how did we die to this team?
What the fuck?
We all died from different people.
Because I died from this team.
And then Mac died from another team.
Wait, who are you spectating, Mac?
I'm watching Design's team.
Yeah, I'm watching Design as well.
Oh, okay, so you two died to Design.
I died to this team.
How did you...
How did they not fight each other?
But they fought us.
This is like...
This is like targeted.
Alright.
I need to use the bathroom too.
Mac, can you entertain my chat?
As what?
Can you entertain him?
Alright, I'll be right back.
I was debating just staying completely dead silent and then gaslighting.
I told an amazing story while she was gone.
But I don't think chat would have gone along with it.
Wait, what?
Chat would do what?
Alright.
Game plan.
On the regular maps, yeah, we play defensive.
And then on E-district, because we have Mac, we know things more than everyone else.
Which means we can bully people.
And then we just farm kills like we did game one.
So we get all our kill points on E-district and then we get all our placement points on regular.
And then we get first.
That sounds like a plan to me.
Yeah, that's what I thought we were doing.
That's why I was surprised we were getting a kill.
Perfect.
Wait, I missed a story?
What story did you tell?
I just had to be there.
Sounds like this is the most entertaining we got in years by Mac.
Thank you, Mac.
You're welcome.
I'm glad I could give your stream the best content they've had in years.
I just had to be there.
It's okay, that's why we have VODs, right guys?
I'm going to look back at the VOD and I'm going to see the best story I've ever heard from Mac.
100%.
Landing Dome doubled your score.
Damn.
From one to two.
I'm saying it doubled the one point that we got.
Oh, okay.
We should have really just...
Do you see this Valk who's about to die to OOP?
Oh, never mind.
I was going to say this was you.
I'm not even spectating the same team.
Valk almost died to OOP.
Damn.
Okay, I'm spectating your roommate.
Tempo.
When did you move in with Hal?
After our TSM house ended.
Oh, so is it just you and Hal?
Yeah, TSM house ended.
Reps and Verhulst both went back home.
And they're living with family.
And then I stayed here.
And he had a house here.
So I just moved in.
Oh, yeah.
I was going to say.
He's not even in TSM anymore.
I was like, how are you at his house?
Are you like his...
Do you clean up for him?
No, I'm just the roommate.
Oh, you're just the roommate.
Do you cook for him?
Here and there.
Oh, so you're like his cook.
Yeah, live-in chef.
Yeah, the live-in chef.
That's the dream.
That's my second job.
So when I was in university...
Yeah?
The first year I lived on campus.
So it was dorm and...
A dorm.
It was the same.
Normally what a dorm is.
But for year two and three, I lived with three other guys.
Oh, that sounds terrible.
And it got to the point...
Yeah, it was so bad.
It got to the point where we had mold growing out of our sink.
Oh!
Okay, that sounds like the college experience.
So then...
Then the deal changed to...
The three roommates pay for...
The three roommates pay for the entire rent and all our groceries.
And in return, I cook and clean all of our common areas.
And everyone gets three meals a day.
Monday to Friday.
Three meals?
That's one meal too many.
And then I just, for like two years, I never paid rent or paid for food.
Oh, so you're like...
You're like the live-in maid.
Yeah.
Yeah, you're like the...
Yeah, that's right.
I am a live-in maid.
Oh my god, what was that like?
Being a live-in maid.
Was it just like the anime?
Yeah, I wore an outfit and everything.
Oh my god, you should do that on stream.
Yeah, wait, how many...
What's like a sub-goal for a maid outfit?
Yeah, yeah, what's a sub-goal to recreate it?
Fuck no.
Never.
I ain't doing no sub-goal.
Not even for 50 gifted?
What the fuck?
So Doki's gonna do a maid outfit for 50 gifted?
No, no, you're gonna do...
You're the live-in maid here.
You already have the experience.
Why are you so afraid?
I have the...
You know that fluffy thingy on a stick?
What?
That you use to clean dust?
I don't even know...
You're a fucking duster?
Is that called a duster?
I thought you were the maid.
Oh, I just buy stuff and use it.
I don't know what it's called.
Oh, this fluffy thing looks like it'll deal with dust well.
What's that fluffy thing that dusts stuff?
Okay, I thought it had a name, alright?
Like a specific name.
It's a duster.
That does not involve the words fluffy or duster.
Yeah, because it doesn't involve fluffy.
Wait, they said it's a feather duster, alright?
That's two different things.
Feather is different than fluffy.
Oh man, what a crime.
He forgot the feather part.
Wait, so how many gifted tempo for a maid stream?
I'm gonna need 10k for a maid stream because I will have to live that down.
10k gifted or 10k done?
I need 10k subs.
You were a maid before.
What do you mean you can't live it down?
You've done it before.
It's called off stream private.
What if you just show up on...
How many subs if you just show up on Hal's stream?
That's the same thing.
You just like walk by in the background.
Yeah, just walk by his background and just clean something and then that's it.
Let me just dust your pictures over here.
Yeah, just turn around.
Turn around, bend over and...
And Hal's background.
That would be so...
Oh my god.
My professionalism would be gone out the window.
I hope now it will be gone.
Nobody is like...
People will be like, no we can't join tempo streams.
Have you not seen Hal's stream today?
Oh my god.
Oh man.
If you don't...
If it was 1k it would have been feasible.
But 10k...
I am not doing that.
You're not selling your soul for 1k subs.
That's a lot of money already.
You know those questions where it's like...
Where it's like...
Like you have the option to do...
Would you do this for a million dollars or whatever?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is like one of those.
I would rather make the million dollars myself than do that.
Well, well, Mac.
Do you have a price?
Do I have a price?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's stay on topic here.
This is about tempo.
I'm just wondering.
Motherfuckers want to be like, oh yeah.
I need 20k subs.
I'm just saying, Mac.
I'm more expensive than tempo.
You're more expensive than tempo?
Yeah, see?
There you go.
That's right.
Just because you don't have the...
No, you have less experience.
You should be less expensive.
No, no, no.
Because you don't have the experience to back it up.
That's how...
That's how the real world works.
The real world isn't real.
You might as well do it for free because you're an intern.
Gather the experience.
Oh my god.
Alright, let's see how people do.
Hey, we got two points!
Yippee!
Holy shit, some people got 10 or 11 kills.
How did they get more kills in this...
in this moment versus the other mode?
Oh my god.
Someone said re-drinking.
Ugh.
I can't believe...
I can't believe you used to be a main, Tempo.
I always learn a new thing about you every Twitch Rivals.
Also, Tempo, Also, Tempo, why is Wig not in Twitch Rivals?
You know why?
Still trying to get rid of me.
No, we would be last place...
No, no, I'm just saying we would be last place if Wig was on Twitch Rivals.
If Wig was on our team.
It's tradition.
No, second last place.
We improved.
We got second last place.
So we improved like one tier.
This is actually the best Tempo I have...
No, no, we actually won the game.
We actually won.
Oh shit, I thought I was talking this whole time.
We improved with one game.
We got better with game one than we did last Twitch Rivals.
Yeah, literally...
That game one we did is the best we've ever done.
Versus Wig.
That's the...
That's the most...
No, Wig, Tempo...
I think that was the most points we've ever gained overall.
In one game.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure all we had were single digit games.
We never...
Even overall, we beat our overall point score.
So I'm pretty proud of this.
We're like, we're maybe in sixth place.
I mean... I know.
It's not that bad.
I can't really tell.
We don't know the gun bonuses and stuff.
You know?
Someone's like, how do you keep friends Doki?
Tempo and Wig roasted me live at ALGSB broadcast.
Right now, at best like...
Okay, at best like...
2k people heard what I said.
Wig and Tempo...
Don't think I don't remember Tempo.
You and Wig fucking roasted me in front of...
Roasted me in front of like 80,000 people.
At ALGSB stream.
I get to do what I want right now.
What did they say?
I don't know Tempo, what did you guys say?
I forget.
I don't remember.
My memory...
I don't have short term or long term memory.
I just...
Yeah.
It's okay.
Your brain is just Apex Grimms.
Yeah.
I mean, that's basically it.
When we play Apex, we're all a little special.
Also, I'm pretty sure you were drunk too.
Wait, who's team 7?
Always.
Well, it's Tempo.
That's a given.
Team 7 and team 1.
I appreciate...
Yeah, I remember.
He was definitely fucking plastered.
During ALGS.
Yes, you were.
He doesn't even remember.
Only one of the ALGSs I drank.
Only one, okay.
Yeah, I think.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Only one.
It's not very confident when you said, I think, right after.
So, like, I don't even trust your memory at that point.
Listen.
I don't remember.
Someone in my chat was like, maybe the only one...
the only one he remembers.
Pathfinder, Crypto...
Is it still Spitfire Reef?
Is it Spitfire Reef?
Yeah, still.
Okay, so, like, is it Revival or...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, so we're gonna do our team chats.
Well, no.
Ash, Maggie...
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna play Pathfinder.
Okay, so Path...
So what do we play, Mac?
Um...
Question?
Tempo could play Crypto.
Oh, right.
I'm going Invisible.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, you should literally run in the middle of, like, wherever we're chilling and just get on your drone and go Invis.
But you have to make sure your drone never breaks or you're dead.
Yeah, that's so true.
Don't be in the middle of everybody just in case it breaks.
Like, at least be in, like, a good spot, you know?
Wait, if I'm in Crypto and someone else Cryptos, can they see me?
No, no, no.
You're literally off the grid.
It's Scout or Akimbo P20.
Oh, that Akimbo P20 is so strong!
Oh, so I'll EMP them and then you just Scout them to death.
Yeah!
That's the strat!
Yeah, exactly.
You see where they opened here?
Alright, we got our plan.
Alright.
You could play...
Caustic or, like...
You could play Ash or Maggie if you want, or Loba.
You could play whatever you want, yeah.
Do you want a controller for beacon though?
Pick whatever you want here.
No, because Pathfinder has a...
Wait, no, I can't...
Don't give me free will.
It won't work well.
Wait, can Pathfinder scan both of them or just one?
Well, you can hit your abilities.
I have the other, never mind.
Yeah, and then I can hit ring consoles.
And then...
You have free will.
No, I don't want that!
This is why I passed the Captive!
Go Ash.
Go Ash so you can run away in case.
Alright, I'll go Ash.
Okay.
Nah, nah, nah, nah.
Go Maggie.
Maggie?
Okay.
Yeah, don't listen to Tempo.
Wait, Maggie can also run away.
I forgot.
Maggie can run away, but Maggie can also get up in some guts if we're, like, breaching someone.
You EMP and we Maggie ball through their fucking door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
FBI, open up!
Just fucking bust in their building with an EMP.
And then...
And then Tempo, all he has to do is just be alive.
Wait, where did we land last game?
So low.
We landed on some guy that was their lifeline.
And we killed him.
We had an actual POI too, right?
No, we did not land on that POI.
We literally just followed somebody.
The thing that I was gonna land on was not a POI.
It was a no-name next to a POI.
And I was gonna cyber-bully that team.
Alright, well let's do that again.
That was my plan.
That person will continuously be our free kill.
That one guy.
They're like, there's no way we're gonna land on a second time.
What are the odds?
How do they know?
We're very stubborn and stupid.
We have nothing to lose.
I'm so excited.
Is this like six games?
Like the usual?
Might be eight.
Could be twelve.
Okay, now I'm fucking gonna look at it.
Now...
I do not have that much time in my life.
What's the thought of being stuck with us for eight or more games?
I told them we're just gonna land whatever has a beacon and a player scan.
So no one will know until the game starts.
Nice.
I don't think anybody cares to be fair.
I don't think anyone can keep track.
That's when we triple land on them.
Yeah, that guy they got triple landed on.
I bet he cared.
I bet that guy cared a lot.
I wish I knew.
Guys, do you guys know who we landed on that one solo?
Does anyone know?
Oh wait, I killed a guy with a Spitfire.
I should get a bonus point for that now.
Wait, was that first game?
The World's Edge game?
Yeah, the World's Edge game.
Yeah, did you tell them?
Do you have to tell them?
I think so.
I feel like they have a way to track it.
By the way, I got a kill.
Twitch.
Rivals.
Schedule.
Get involved.
Wait, wrong button.
Next tournament.
Bracket.
Leaderboard.
Okay, the leaderboard is on the Twitch Rivals page, but it is not up here.
Oh, they said we got those, no worry.
It was like, good job, Alb!
Huge!
You're killing it.
Let's go.
My friends are so supportive.
They're so supportive.
They said hit the red button.
They would never make fun of me.
Yeah!
They're giving you moral support.
Is that design for Astro Mode on?
That was like, good job, Alb!
Yeah, that was fun.
Alright guys, here's my gaslighting, by the way.
Guys.
This is what I wrote.
You have to report each kill right after or it doesn't count.
Fucking hell.
If you reply to him with, I guess you won't have to report anything then.
I can't say that because I'm not a pro player.
OG kill race.
Yeah, where you'd fucking screenshot your scores and send it in with a timestamp of your bod.
Oh no!
I hate this!
Oh my god, I remember that.
I remember this too!
I swear, we had a tournament That shit sucked.
We had a tournament like a few months ago where...
it was a company it was an org or a company or whatever that did an event back then and then they came back and did an event like recently and they were like, yeah, you gotta screenshot the results so we can put it in because they haven't been in Apex for like years.
Yeah.
That sounds terrible.
Yeah, they're like, hey, screenshot it and send it to us and all the players were like, what the fuck?
That sounds fucking terrible.
Holy shit.
I just remembered I hated those kill races though Alright, team 10 is a duo.
Int them!
Do you have the scores?
No.
Are you keeping score?
This is what I think it is, but I don't know.
Because it doesn't have the special guns.
This one doesn't have the special guns.
The fact that you're going to...
Or the Rivals guys said that we need a Polaroid submitted to Twitch HQ.
And Watson got minus 5, I think?
Must be mailed via USPS.
Bruh.
You guys are tied for second, kind of.
Wait, you're keeping track of Hal's team too?
Like...
What?
You're keeping track of Hal's scores?
How?
I'm keeping track of all of our scores.
Yeah, but you don't know their bonus points.
Oh yeah, without the bonus points.
The only thing I'm keeping track of is the actual match summary.
So it should be kind of close, right?
I thought you said you were off work.
Why are you helping Hal keep track?
Because I want to make sure the teams that pick the wrong...
Oh true, it's his rules.
I want to make sure the people that pick the wrong character...
I want to make sure they get the negative 5.
That's so fucked up.
I like making people's lives miserable.
Bruh, and you guys say I'm toxic.
Bruh, that's the most fucking toxic thing I've heard.
You fucked up?
Minus 5.
We won't forget.
Jesus Christ.
Yo, the two teams are still in the negatives, okay?
Are they actually?
Holy shit, wait.
Okay, we're sure of 4.
Negative 1 and negative 3.
Oh my god.
Team 15, where are you?
There's no way.
Oh wait, and that one's accurate because they didn't get any kills the second game.
No, no, because they have placement.
They're 6th place last game.
Yeah, that only gets you 12, 9, 7, 5, 4, 3?
That only gets you 3 points.
Oh, so they're... okay.
Wait, what am I playing again?
Maggie.
Okay, where is she?
She's in the middle of the screen.
Quite literally.
Okay, guys, we might get minus 5.
We might get our minus 5 on first pick.
I already picked Crypto.
Oh, thank god, okay.
Guys, guys, okay.
Oh, thank god, thank you.
I will highlight this for you, so you do not miss it.
Guys, if anybody's getting the minus 5, it's me.
I'm waiting for someone else to minus 5 right now.
With this comp, unironically, we can go door-to-door and just blow people up.
I actually know how to play this properly.
As long as Crypto doesn't kill his fucking drone.
I'm ready.
Bro, okay, you're putting so much hope on the fact that Temple doesn't kill his drone.
Yo, I have 28 kills with Crypto.
Oh, Jesus.
That's actually 28 more than I thought.
Only god can help us.
That's 28 more than I thought.
Because I don't remember when I played Crypto.
Wait, oh, my game is not...
Oh, there we go.
Good chance we might just insta-jump if I don't see anybody go straight down.
Okay.
Wait, what are we doing?
This is called boardwalk, I think.
Oh, wait, nobody's here?
Wait, no one's at that POI either.
There's a solo going over there.
There's one person!
I'm going towards you, you cunt!
You guys better watch out, Tempo's inbound.
Oh, no!
Tempo, the biggest threat right now!
He sees you!
Yeah, I'm the biggest griefer.
I should be scared.
Wait, how do I get out of this building?
What were the guns again?
Scout and akimbo P20.
Okay, that's...
Alright, I'll do that.
I'll run a scout.
Well, I was going to say, you might want to run a shotgun on Maggie.
The akimbo Milsims.
Yeah, I got the akimbo Milsims.
I have it right now.
Yeah, yeah.
Use it, use it.
Then who's going to do the P20?
Charge rifle?
Okay.
I just think we won't.
Oh, okay.
Alright, good talk, good talk.
What is going on over there?
Did Hal fucking die?
I guess so.
What the fuck happened to him?
Alright, I looted.
I looted here.
Where?
Where did the solo go?
He was too far.
Let him get away.
Let him get away?
I thought you had your eyes on him.
I did.
I hit a wall.
And then I was like, well...
Well, I guess he's gone.
Wait, I found an evil harvester.
We can rat this.
We can rat this?
We're not ratting an evil harvester.
Should I do fireball?
Or shots, shots, shots?
The auto-reload?
The auto-reload.
Okay, auto-reload shotguns on Nox?
Yeah, and then you're gonna Kimbo Mozambiques.
We need to get you hammer points.
Why do I have 18 nades like I'm playing Fuse?
I don't know.
I'm still looking for a scout as well.
We need...
Oh, they're killing people already.
Do we have like any...
Oh, yeah, we need to find people scanner.
Do I need that?
No.
Wait, people scanner here, right?
Do we have one?
We should have a people scanner.
Do you need this, Cookie?
Yes, I do.
I have a blue.
Should I scan this now?
Yeah, hit it.
We can just see where we're at.
Oh, wait, what?
There's two people coming to us.
Just trying to get kills.
They're literally running right at us.
Yeah, we can kill them.
I think I heard a crypto scan, but not from you.
Yeah, play up with me.
Where are they?
They should be over here, Tempo.
You're going the wrong way.
Yeah, but he should stay hidden in case we all got away.
No, he's on his drone.
Okay, okay.
They should be around here.
Fast and Furious!
Flash, flash, flash!
Over here.
Yeah.
Can you drill that guy's door?
Yeah, I'm fucking...
I didn't drill the door, but...
I'm on him.
Fast and Furious!
Excellent.
Yippee!
Wait, did we thirst the other guy, or no?
I don't know where the other guy went.
He said, I got two kills from that.
You got two kills?
Nice.
Do I get out of this?
No, you're chilling.
Tokyo Drift!
Alright, should we do the ring scan?
Yeah, yeah.
We just look for kills over here.
No, Tempo, you didn't scan the ring.
I called that beacon.
You gotta be off the grid.
You have to be invisible, Tempo.
Tempo!
Wait, do I move faster if I'm on the ground?
Oh yeah, I do.
Tokyo Drift!
Let's get scootin'.
We'll start scootin' along this way and hit the CIV.
Let's go, Tempo.
Get out of the drone.
Okay.
Which is this way?
This way?
Are you orange?
Yes.
I am orange.
Alright, I'm heading over.
If I die first, then just don't go my way and I'll just respawn.
Okay.
That's literally what we need to do.
Who's ready to fly on a zip line?
I made us a zip, Tempo.
I am!
Alright.
Oh.
You made him a zip and not...
Fast and Furious!
Um.
I will not be there.
Because I'm blue.
I'm getting crypto-droned.
Sir.
I broke their drone.
Let's commit four crimes.
Wait, where are they?
Over here.
Alright, Tempo.
You gotta be invisible.
I gotta go hide in the toilet.
Tempo, get on your drone.
Get rid of the EMP of them.
Alright.
I'm not in the toilet, but you know.
Yeah, I'm waiting.
I'm literally on the bottom.
They're in here.
Okay.
Is it more than one team?
No, it's just one.
Just one.
You have the range?
Hey, guys.
Oh, shit!
I just whiffed so badly.
I'm gonna bleed out.
Okay.
I suck with these moves.
What?
I'm Tokyo Drifting!
Tokyo Drifting!
I can't tell you.
No!
He's one!
He's literally one!
Goodbye.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm still alive.
He's literally one!
If he wasn't so fucking chunky!
Oh, shit!
My drone died.
Oh, I'm in zone.
Wait, what?
Wait, why am I not respawning?
Oh, okay.
Four seconds.
Yeah, I was, like, spectating.
Wait, where do we land?
All I know is I just need more meds.
We just hold this team.
Okay.
We stay on this side of the wall, we just go this way, and we try to kill these guys.
Alright, I'm dropping in.
Hit one for 60.
What the fuck?
Why am I floating?
Like...
I'm just gracefully floating down.
I hate this.
What is under me?
I'm not really landing at a very ideal spot.
I'm in this house.
Oh, don't get farmed!
I broke that crypto drone again.
One's on the roof, right here.
You pinged them?
He's trying to gasnade me.
I'm looking.
I'm healing.
Yeah, our lifeline is healing right now.
Yeah, Tempo, just go all the way around that way, okay?
I found them.
They're on...
Do you have EMP, Tempo?
Nope.
60%.
They made a...
They made a zip.
Is that a zip?
No, never mind.
Is that...
I can't see that properly.
They are over there.
Oh, there's...
Their crypto drone is here.
Shoot that shit!
I'm trying to shoot it, but then they're shooting me, too.
Wait, where am I?
Wait, they got EMP'd by someone else.
Yeah.
Come to me, come to me.
Okay.
You have to stay low ground.
You can't...
You're not gonna be able to get up here.
I think I broke their drone with my fucking drill.
Tempo, we're going.
We're moving.
Goodbye, Tempo.
Wait, I'm trying to hit this shit.
Tempo, goodbye.
Oh.
We gotta go street market.
Okay.
We have 43 seconds, though.
Oh, wait.
That's the only team that's here.
Yeah.
Wait, then whose drone did I fucking...
break?
They were just EMP'ing themselves.
Yeah, I was like, what?
Probably a solo hidden crypto somewhere.
Yeah, but you didn't see any.
That's the thing.
Who ran away as soon as the drone died.
Let's try as heat shields are on.
Ooh.
I have a heat shield.
Yeah.
It's not whatchamacallit mode.
We gotta go-go.
We have 14 seconds.
Yo, there's super bins soon.
Yeah, yeah.
We're gonna come in like over...
Omega little bins.
I'm going up first.
With 18 million goals.
I'm going second.
Tempo, you just hit this.
Hit this on the way.
On the way.
Oh, I hear lots of gunshots in front of us.
Mhm.
I don't like the sound of that.
We should have high ground up here.
To look down on some free kills.
Alright.
But what if they're there too?
Wait, Tempo, do you have enough meds?
Tempo?
What?
You have enough meds?
Okay.
I have four syringes.
Oh, yay.
Oh, there's two people in front of us.
Oh, three.
Never mind.
It's three.
They should...
We should be able to hold them.
Where?
On the other side of this building.
Okay.
I hear them.
I feel like they're ratting.
I'm gonna peek.
Okay.
They're in here.
I'm gonna full heal then.
Tempo's with us, so like...
I'm just running.
Tempo, get on your drone.
Go invis.
And I think we might kill the ghost.
Oh, it just broke it.
Oh, no.
I'm dead.
Tempo, we need you to live.
We need you to live.
I'm gonna bleed out.
No, he found me.
He found me.
You have to live through the zone.
Run, Doki.
No, it's Mac, and I'm worried he's gonna die in zone.
Fucking heals.
You have no heals?
I'm not in zone and I died.
I wasn't in zone.
I wasn't even in the zone on my screen.
Oh, my God.
He died to leg.
Wait, did you have no heals?
I had no radials.
I'm gonna give you my heals.
I thought I was fine.
I thought you were fine.
You had no heals.
I wasn't even in that zone and I just died.
Oh, my God.
Wait, how did they find you, Tempo?
I don't know.
How did they find me?
How did they find you?
Wait, they can hear you?
Yeah, he makes a noise.
He makes like a humming noise.
Wait, really?
I didn't...
Oh, my God.
The moment Tempo was right next to us, I knew it was over.
I should have moved deeper into the thing.
Our lifeline was gone.
Wait, was this Evan's team that killed us?
I have no idea.
I almost destroyed the drone, too.
It sucked.
It was so close.
Damn.
Wait, somebody... their third DC'd.
Their third literally lost.
He left the game.
Wait, that sucks.
The fuck was their third?
Wait, he's... their third is out out.
Whoever team this is.
Oh, yeah, it's Evan.
Evan just... what?
Evan's third literally got kicked out of the game.
He's not dead yet, so...
Yeah, it's not last.
Wait...
Did you guys get both kills with a special gun?
No, I had a Mos-M.
Is Mos-M not...
No, it's P20 and...
and Scout.
But we got two kills.
Okay, all good.
We are now at 20.
Yeah, no matter what, this is a lot better than how we usually do, Tempo.
20 points is more than we got.
And Challenger's so good, so...
Oh, no, wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, it's more than we got in overall Twitch Rivals with Wig, so that's all that matters.
I think the most points we got was like 15 or some shit in Twitch Rivals.
Alright, I think this means we're gonna get like...
7?
Like 8?
9?
10?
Or 11?
12?
Give me hope.
I don't want to go in with...
I want to go in with low expectations.
Every Rivals, we've gotten in the middle, except for that one with Wig.
Every Rivals, we've gotten like middle of... like even the...
in-person stuff, we got like in the middle.
Yeah, but then like...
with the last two of Wig, we got last and second last.
The reason they could see Tempo is because if you bleed out or get full killed, it scans the team.
Wait, if who bleeds out?
Like a different teammate?
Yeah, I bleed out and I expose Tempo.
It's okay, we might restart.
We might restart because apparently a bunch of teams are getting DC'd.
Because server is crashing.
Because I guess... wait, what hour?
Stop the game right now.
We started this at 4.
The server shouldn't crash.
That's weird.
Wait, but they're still playing the game.
It's only an hour and 50...
If the server was launched at 4 o'clock...
Wait, but they're still playing the game though.
Yeah.
Let's let more people DC and then they have to restart.
Okay, wait.
How many people DC'd?
I'm gonna check chat.
Is the server shut down?
I said it would happen.
Oh, people are saying...
Apparently that's a thing.
I got 1, 2, 3...
4...
4 people.
How can you see where people are saying they DC'd?
It's literally in the chat.
They're talking about who...
Public lobby code closes every 2 hours.
Interesting.
I feel like they won't...
They'll count this and just be like...
Not if the entire server closes.
Can't count it if more than 10 teams are still alive and the server goes...
GG.
So we need the server to explode right now.
Someone quick...
Someone horizon...
Someone horizon ult in the middle of the square.
Wait, I'll say I DC'd.
Oh yeah, me too.
5 people DC'd, we have to restart now.
Tempo, you should say it.
They trust you more than my word.
Yeah, you should be like...
Don't comment.
Bro.
Trust me, bro.
No, they're not.
It just says that we're just gonna create a new code.
Well, if the entire server crashes, that's a different story, right?
If the game doesn't actually end.
We just gotta hope it blows up in the next like...
2-3 minutes.
That's a lot of hope right now.
Crash, crash, crash.
Only 4 people DC'd.
We're just connected.
Yo, that's a solid...
Wait, okay, but if you say...
Tempo, you should tell them that you DC'd too.
So then it adds a 5th person into it.
No, no, no, you tell them.
No, no, you tell them.
I don't wanna get banned from Rivals.
This punk.
Yeah, but they can't ban you.
They can't ban you.
You're like the heart of Apex.
Oh my god.
Dude, I wasn't even invited normally.
What do you mean?
Someone said in my chat, unplug Hal, then they'll restart.
Oh no.
This seems to be his internet connection.
Oh my god, Hal just needs to DC and then they'll restart the server.
Oh, this is going too quick.
We need people to DC.
I know, I don't think they're gonna restart.
Too many people have died already.
Come on server, go boom.
Yeah, people are like, alright, fine.
They've accepted it.
To be fair, to be fair, Verhulst's team is doing really well for having only two people.
Like, literally, he literally got six kills.
Oh my god, he's literally the only person in this team that's getting kills right now.
That's crazy.
That's mean, there's only one other person on his team.
Yeah, but like...
And he got all the kills with P20 and Scout.
Yeah, so he has 12 points.
That's crazy.
Mac, plug in your controller.
Mac, why did you go back to MNK?
What the fuck?
Because he knew aim assist nerf was coming.
Oh my god.
He's like, suck it bitches, I'm back on movement.
How did you know?
Who leaked it to you?
That's illegal.
Insider trading.
Yeah.
Can't believe you went back to MNK.
It's such a shocker.
Wow.
Don't worry.
In the next year, you'll go back to controller.
Yep.
It's gonna be a pattern.
Oh yeah, didn't they do the controller overclocking thingy just now too?
What's that?
Oh.
You can hack your controller.
Yeah.
Oh shit, and you left...
And you left controller?
It's not good.
Wait, okay, Tempo.
But how did they do that?
I have no clue.
Basically, one of their controller sponsors, like their primary controller sponsor, made an overclocking software so now it's considered a first party software.
Is that bad?
Wait, does that mean everyone who's playing ALGS, if they want to overclock, they have to use a battle beaver?
Wait, is it battle beaver?
That did it?
Yeah, it does.
Oh, and is there newer controllers that does it?
No, it's all their rollers.
Oh, because it's like a software?
You can overclock a base PS4 or PS5.
Yeah, it's a software.
Let me grab my battle beaver real quick.
Let me switch to my controller real quick.
So you're saying...
So what does overclocking do?
Wait, I also have a battle beaver.
It basically increases the responsiveness of your roller.
It's like polling rate on mice.
You're overclocking the polling rate on your controller.
Wait, where does it show my polling rate on my mouse?
So you're saying...
is that...
I am at...
That's not DPI, right?
It's not cheating because it's part of the roller.
Wait, can I...
Where's my polling rate?
Well, actually...
It's not...
Apparently it's not overclocking the roller itself.
It's overclocking the USB hub or some shit.
Oh, so you can still do it and use other controllers, I guess?
Yeah.
So...
Team 7.
Okay, so it's Janja's team.
Damn.
Team 9 is Zap.
Wait, where's team 15 and...
Team 9 is Zap?
Where's team 15 and 5?
15 got 15th and 0.
Team 5 got 17th but 7 killed.
We didn't know we're team 8.
Team 5 made it out of the negatives.
We did it.
I'm so proud of them.
Team 15 is still in the negatives.
Okay.
Oh, no way, no way.
They're at 0 points now.
Yeah, they got out.
I'm proud of them.
Holy shit.
Does the Twitch Rivals...
Does the Twitch Rivals not give scores at all?
They said they are.
I just smacked a fly out of the air with my mouse.
Guys, is Twitch Rivals giving scores out on their stream?
Or like...
Because we're not getting the scores at all.
That's why Hal went in to ask us what the scores are.
I switched to a fly.
A fly with my mousepad.
Are there like...
fucking guts on your...
I'm going to disappear for a sec.
A fly with my mouse, not my mousepad.
Wait, does that mean you're going to disappear?
Does that mean there's like guts...
There's guts on your mousepad now?
I have no clue.
Oh, wait, the scores are up.
I just don't know how many games this is in.
We're in game 3.
We just finished game 3.
Okay, the scores are up for only 2 games.
Like after 2 games.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Wait, why do we only have 5 points?
Wait, what?
What?
We got 15 kills.
Do they not count kills in Revives?
I don't know.
But...
This next game...
On Storm Point...
Boosted Gun is Alternator Charge Rifle.
Hey, that's your gun.
Oh, boy.
Oh, boy, oh, boy.
Wait, they don't count kills on the first game?
That's fucked!
Wait, really?
I don't know!
He said we got 5 points in 2 games.
It said...
I'm pretty sure they just didn't include the kills yet.
Because it says you still get 1 point per kill.
I'm so confused.
Blah, blah, blah.
Format, blah, blah, blah.
Each map will have a set of feature wins that will award extra points for a kill.
What?
You get extra points for a kill.
But you still get points for a normal kill.
Each kill, only in Standard Battle Royale, equals 1 point.
Where?
It says it under the scoring.
Replacement.
In format.
Oh my god!
What?
So kills in Revival don't matter?
Why the fuck are people killing?
No.
We're making up with kills in this game.
We're griefing people.
Wait, where does that say it?
I just found it.
Guys.
Mac.
We're not reading rules again.
This is Day Shop.
We're doing it again, Mac!
Wait, what do you mean again?
Did this happen to you guys last time?
Wait, wait, wait.
Alter, Rev.
And part Newcastle.
We didn't read the rules again!
Not again.
That's so funny.
But
the else is reading the rules because everyone is sending two people out to get kills!
Everyone!
Oh no.
Alright, well.
We can make up for kills with this game.
You should have known this.
I blame you.
You're the format guy.
You should have known this.
You let us astray.
It'd be weird.
Don't worry.
This is why people have so little kills.
I'll make up with 10 charge rifle kills here, which is 20 kills.
Alright?
Don't worry.
Okay, so like.
What do we play?
Alter, Rev.
Bloodseer.
Caustic, Rampart.
Gibby, Newcastle.
Okay, Mac.
What do we play?
We need placements.
I got Rampart.
Alright.
Uh.
There's no group moving character.
These cops are fucking awful.
Yeah, there's no group moving character.
This is so cursed what I'm looking at, man.
My brain is trying so hard to like formulate something.
Rampart, Newcastle.
You just build Fortnite.
Yeah, I think we have to build a motel.
With Rampart, Newcastle.
And then...
And then we should probably get a recon scan, right?
Caustic?
Wait, Caustic, Rampart, Newcastle?
Yeah.
So which one do I play?
Which one do you want to play?
I'm good with any.
Except for Rampart.
Probably Caustic.
Okay, I got this.
I have Santa Claus Caustic too.
So I'm going to give Christmas cheer.
Oh, yo.
We just build a Fortnite.
Yeah, that's what they've been doing to us.
That's what we're going to do.
We're going to play three charge rifles.
We're going to build a hotel.
And we're going to cyber bully the lobby.
Okay, we just got to have good zone prediction.
Which I'm pretty sure Matt can do for us.
Let me just...
Wait, what if...
There we go.
Okay, what are you cooking?
What if...
You see my reply in chat?
What if we play...
Newcastle, Gibby, Rampart?
Newcastle, Gibby, Rampart.
So you would be Gibby then, Doggy.
Okay, I will be Gibby.
Or Mac.
What do I do?
They're both crucial roles.
I don't know which one is more important.
Now we'll be on the important one, right?
Yeah, you'll play Gibby.
I'll play Gibby?
Okay.
Wait, why?
Didn't you get a kill with a Scout or a P20 last game?
No.
I shot somebody with a Spitfire.
Oh wait, yeah, Spitfire...
Was Spitfire not the gun?
No, it was Scout or P20.
What was the boosted gun again?
Charge Rifle Alternator.
Okay, I'll grab the Alternator.
I'm going to be honest, I'm probably going to play with a shotgun.
Okay.
And just ignore the bonus points.
I'll get us the bonus points.
Yeah, I'll get Alternator.
And then, yeah, I can't do a Charge Rifle.
No, you have to.
You have to.
I can!
No, you're doing it.
I don't care if you think you can't.
You will.
Guys, I just chat.
And you guys should know, Tempo's Charge Rifle level is 87.
Yes, I fucking see it.
I fucking see this cursed shit right now that you fucking showed everybody else in the next chat.
I'm coming.
I'm coming for everyone.
Everyone's going to die.
This is Tempo's fucking Charge Rifle stats.
I forgot where I said we were going.
Um, me too.
Dome.
Oh wait, Storm Point?
Oh shit, Mel!
Mel, Mel, Mel.
No, I said Zeus.
I changed it.
Oh, Zeus, okay.
Wait, we landed Hotstone.
Yes, we did.
And we got two points.
One was the freebie and one was the kill.
That's how we got our five.
Guys, are we going to perform worse than with Vig on our team?
If that happens...
We're getting 20 points this game, so that'll boost us to what, 25?
Hang on.
Disaster striking, hang on.
People are like arguing right now regarding point distribution.
I feel like something is off.
People are not happy.
about the points distribution right now.
I see a lot of arguing in chat.
Someone said, Guy spent a third of his life trolling with charge rifle.
That's tempo.
Wait, what?
You spent a third of your life just playing on chat.
That's why I still have fun playing the game, alright?
I only play to troll people.
Yo, wait, wait, wait.
Did people, did they give the players their minus points?
If they didn't add the minus points, you can ask them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yo.
Yo, where are the minus fives at?
Homie.
Okay, we may in fact
I might have a plan.
I want to see a negative point team after six games.
Damn.
That's fucked.
At least that means like, you know, they'll still they can still get money even with negative points.
We will be Coastal Camp, I think.
Okay.
Doesn't matter.
Oh wait, doesn't Coastal Camp have the thingy with the charge rifle?
Yes, it has a sniper tower.
That's specifically why I'm picking it.
Oh yeah, baby.
So that we have a good chance of getting a charge rifle.
I believe in us.
There's no way.
We're gonna break ten points, right?
Yeah.
Guys.
We're gonna get hot zone on Coastal.
I'll be right back.
Where's the thingy?
Is there no They didn't do it.
Oh, no hotspot landing for this one.
Oh, okay.
Wait, did Mac pick his character?
That's a very good question.
Uh oh.
Maybe if I leave, they won't start.
You picked yours though, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Gibby.
Someone in my chat said he did not.
Oh.
Guys, as soon as your countdown, I'll leave the game.
So they'll have to...
Mac?
Mac is in bathroom.
Oh, my God.
He better pee fast.
I've been making fun of negative five teams this whole time.
This is karma.
This is literally karma.
Oh, no.
Leaderboard.
Leaderboard is total scores.
Hotspot detailed is raw points.
What does hotspot mean?
Oh, he's back.
Oh, thank God.
Oh.
Wait.
Okay, so leaderboard is total...
What did he just say?
Hotspot details is raw points.
Hotspot is if you landed in the hotspot.
So we have to have six points.
Because we landed in the hotspot once, right?
I'm getting water.
I reselected path.
Why is my chat gaslighting me?
It's okay.
Team six is missing someone.
So we're good.
Why is Ruby of all people gaslighting me?
That was the coach.
Why am I being gaslit by my coach?
All right.
I'm back.
Is everything good for you guys?
Oh, we're starting.
We're about to shotgun a Red Bull.
For the charge rifle of the century.
Jesus Christ.
I'm drinking water.
You're fucking shotgunning a Red Bull.
Okay.
I'm ready.
Jesus Christ.
My face is now in my screen.
Oh my God.
I'm ready to charge rifle, people.
I'll take a bite out of my wrap.
I now look like Zero with my face in my monitor.
He won the World Cup.
No, they got second.
Oh, yeah.
Because I missed a bunch of Kraber shots.
I almost forgot.
Wait.
I can't see a lot if I'm this close to the monitor.
Embo, pick your character.
It's Rampart, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
I also forgot.
You know that I freaked out, Doki.
I also didn't remember.
She was like, wait a minute, wait a minute.
Well, that Gibby skin is fire.
Got the camo drip.
That's right.
They can't see me if I'm camouflage.
You will be in a tree.
Can't see me if I'm hiding in a tree.
Yeah, they'll just think she's a coconut.
Definitely not a Gibby.
If we kill someone, they'll see my banner and they'll see level 87 charge rifle and then I'll teabag them.
Just don't die.
Bad news, my mouse died.
I have to play Wired.
Heck, why didn't you fucking charge your mouse right now?
My mouse isn't working.
No, it's just in game.
My mouse actually isn't dead.
Oh, shit.
You gotta alt F4 and then rejoin the game.
That happened to me.
I had to restart my game completely.
I had to alt tab.
Thank god I didn't listen to Tempo.
I didn't listen to this guy.
It didn't work when I alt tabbed.
Holy shit.
I'm glad you like...
I'm glad you doubted it.
Even if you alt F4 and restarted, we would have just landed at Coastal by the time you got in.
Shit.
I think I have the fucking sword heirloom equipped on this guy.
Look, Evan told me how to fly.
Look at this fucking fuuuu...
perfect flight path.
Where do we even loot?
All I know is I'm going on that triangle thingy.
I'm right here.
I have Evan flying.
I have skills.
I got my charge rifle.
Let me know you find an alternator.
There's like four wingmans here.
What the fuck?
That shit's fucked.
I'm going to play charge rifle Mastiff.
Imagine zone ends here.
Nevermind, it's already picked up.
I'm still trying to find my I'm still trying to find my alternator.
Oh, I found my alternator.
North pad zone?
Let's see.
Is there another charge rifle up there?
No, there's only one.
There's a sniper stock here.
Only one charge rifle up there.
Hey, here's another one.
Found one.
I have one, yeah.
I'm not going to run it because I don't know how to use it.
Alright, this is already looted.
Okay.
Actually, not that much loot over here.
I stopped using charge rifle when they made it worse.
When they made it harder?
Yeah.
I tapped out just like that.
I'm not here to learn.
I'm here to plateau.
I need a six or a four eights.
Alright, cappy ten.
Lead us.
To the promised land.
We're going this way.
Let's get out of here.
Alright.
Our goal is to break ten points in the end.
Barometer is coming up.
If we don't break ten points, man...
If we don't break ten points, our team is worse than when Wig is on our team.
I don't know if I can...
No.
If the charge rifle is a bonus gun, this is good.
I'm just grabbing this Eva.
When he scans the beacon, I'm going to shoot his ass off.
Okay.
What should I get?
Do I get shots, shots, shots, refresh...
Oh, revive allies, right?
He is not scanning the beacon.
You can take the revive if you want.
Yeah, I'll do that.
It depends if you're running a shotgun.
If you're not running a shotgun, then don't take shot shots.
Let's go.
We're going this way, boys.
Alright.
They just scanned us, by the way, so they know we're here.
It's probably fine.
Okay.
I trust you.
Questionable.
Okay.
You're making me doubt my choices.
They're holding us.
Where?
Oh, there.
I think I'm going to hold over there and shoot for you guys.
Flesh!
Oh, I can't shoot through the fucking fence?
I ulted over.
I'm going to shot from back, too.
I cracked one here.
I'm going to bat.
Almost knocked one.
Rev is sliding up on you guys.
You guys should kill that guy.
He's there alone.
He's completely alone on that rock.
I'm reloading.
He's close to you.
He's in front of me.
Flesh, I cracked him.
I cracked him.
They're going to push now.
Okay.
Well, I cracked the other dude.
Wait, I thought Tempo... what?
I thought you guys took it.
Tempo ran away.
I don't know.
I said to kill that guy and Tempo was like, I'm going the other way.
I thought we were all running to you.
He said to kill the Revenant that was on you because he was alone.
And you just left her alone.
It's okay.
We can craft her.
I heard the call!
Just completely abandoned her.
I definitely did not hear that.
What?
What do you mean you didn't?
I was just following arrows.
I will admit, he probably said it.
I definitely did.
That's why she's dead.
I would have ran back!
Okay, I'm just as airheaded as Doggy.
So we're good.
I listened to the call!
What call?
Oh my god, it could have been a lie.
All I know is...
We can craft her.
Somewhere.
Wait, we can't craft her.
Where are all the crafters?
There's a crafter here.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe you did tell me to back off after Tempo did it.
I didn't even realize that he just ignored the comm completely.
I looked to my left and I was like, oh there's Tempo running past me.
As you were dead.
I'm here guys!
Mack, maybe you were right.
Maybe I should have got the fire dragon guy.
Okay.
Don't worry.
It's all going according to plan.
What, me dying?
That's part of the plan?
What plan is it?
You're a sacrificial part of our rotate.
I hope.
Oh my god, I hope there's nobody there.
Don't worry, everyone already rotated to zone.
I like how my chat was like, Tempo replaces auditory sensors with score tracking.
Hey!
The game doesn't have audio to begin with, okay?
I don't need auditory sensors.
And even then, the score tracking wasn't even accurate.
That's the worst part.
The score tracking was so inaccurate because we didn't read the rules.
That's a...
I blame Doki for that one.
How do you blame me?
I gave captain to...
I pawned off my captain.
Imagine if I accidentally crafted a wrong thing.
Did you actually?
I'm raising you up here.
Come this way.
Is that a person?
Am I tweaking?
I'm tweaking.
Guys, apparently the fire dragon guy is first place.
What?
Not to say that Tempo wasn't the best choice.
Don't worry, we could be first place.
Wait, what about Zap?
What about Zap's team?
We don't need to worry about that.
Our placement is Zap's team.
Let's waddle on over here.
You said there's a team up here?
All the way up at command, yeah.
I got shot at while landing.
But behind me.
I might be dead here.
I mean from above.
You're probably okay.
I don't feel okay.
You're probably fine.
It's just anxiety.
Don't worry doggy.
That's just everyday life for me.
I'm right behind you.
No, that's not anxiety because I feel that every day.
Someone just flew in here on the right.
Maybe we just chill over here and build a little hotel.
Yeah, let's just start building.
There's probably someone here, but we'll find out.
Who the fuck be flying?
Someone's flying in in front of us.
I hit the Gibby.
This flew in in front of us.
Okay.
That's probably fine.
I'm gonna grab some meds after all this.
They're trying to evac.
Oh shit, okay.
I'm waiting for the balloon to go up.
Yeah, tempo, get Sheila out.
Shoot the last one.
Where's the last one?
I hit something and then I know where it is.
I can't stand this guy.
Wait, the last one already left?
I was charge rifling them.
I can't stand this guy.
Wait, I'm lagging.
No, the server is fucked right now.
Are we killing house here?
I'll take the evac.
Oh no, it's gonna disappear.
It's a disaster.
Guys, I think...
Are we lagging?
The server is lagging right now.
Are you lagging too, Mac?
Yeah.
I guess we build a house here.
We build a house, yeah.
No wonder I no-regged.
Okay, that made more sense.
I heard hit register shots.
Are we farming the spiders or nah?
Yeah, yeah.
And we got a care pack on us?
This is auditory.
This is really on and off.
They really did trade that for proper score tracking.
What the fuck?
It wasn't even accurate score tracking.
Sniper stock here.
Why am I getting sniper shit?
I need stuff for my gun.
Oh, where?
Tempo, build a house.
Tempo, house.
I can only put, what, two more walls?
Yeah, I'm chilling up here.
My wall's not very good, I'm not gonna lie.
How do I get a wall up there?
I can't build anything.
You don't.
This is just a me thing.
Yo, there's a Devo.
Someone take that.
Mac's gonna take that, right?
Uh...
I could.
Mac, you are like, literally the only positive thing here in our team.
Shit.
Who the fuck?
What the fuck?
Why were you stuck in there?
Alright, we finished.
Alright, you wanna play fucking Sheila battle?
No.
Fuck your door, you son of a bitch!
They're fighting up here.
We're so fucked.
Please tell me he's not full dead.
He's not.
But we might be.
Tempo.
I don't even know how you died.
They were cheating.
I don't even...
Oh, fellas.
This is not looking good.
This is not looking good for us.
We don't have an evac.
We gotta just go around.
This is fucked.
Come this way.
We gotta...
Tempo, hurry up.
Open your ears.
Let's go.
We gotta fucking move, buddy.
Yo, five teams already died.
We got one point.
Let's go.
That should not be like...
Let's fucking go, dude.
Easy money.
You're so right.
What would we do without you keeping score?
Come on, Tempo.
Battery?
I'm so glad we had someone that's paying attention to our placement right now.
Yo, we got battery.
Yeah, he's just constantly reminding me, like, we're doing awful.
He's just in my ear, just like, we have five points in four games.
Someone's flying on us.
Come on, hurry up, Tempo.
I'm running.
Keep moving.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
We just need to get far, far away from them.
That's the goal.
Okay.
So what I'm thinking is, we grab this mythic bin in front of us to get another care pack.
Someone just took it.
It's over.
Oh.
We're going this way.
Come with me.
We're gonna go to the right.
Okay.
Yeah, Revenant just grabbed it.
He's about to zip up.
Maybe...
I missed.
I missed again.
He has red armor.
In fact, he has red armor.
Okay.
We're gonna go under here.
It's fine.
Maybe.
If there's people under here, listen, it's gonna be a brawl.
Is Riv a character?
Pull up.
Yeah, he is.
There's a barrel here.
This is fine.
If there's people here, we're brawling.
Okay.
He has red armor and I have blue.
You know...
Yeah?
There's a Sierra in front of me.
Or above us.
It's above us.
We build a house.
We're playing Fortnite.
Yippee!
This is our little house.
Just a little baby.
Hey, we got top 10!
They jumped on the right.
Yep, I'm watching.
Oh.
Just you?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, right there?
I'm not gonna lie.
I think I might run at that guy.
Mac, could you just think about that again?
Mac, just... okay.
Okay.
I made him walk away.
I'm watching the other side.
Can you shoot that guy up top?
I don't have an angle on that guy.
Peek him then.
Okay.
I'm watching our back.
I almost killed one.
Alright.
We need more walls if you can have some walls.
I'm trying to crawl back.
Okay.
Crawl into this.
And then...
They're gonna thirst me.
Okay.
There's just nothing we can do, man.
Get out of there, Doki.
Get out of there.
Alright.
Live on for us.
Live on.
Teppo, I'm gonna distract him.
You live on.
I'm gonna distract him.
I'm distracting them, Teppo.
Just run.
Teppo, run.
Stop running.
You're not here.
I forgot it's a seer.
Teppo, I fucking sacrificed my life and you were gonna hide in it before I was a seer team.
No, there's...
I literally sacrificed my life and Teppo's like, I'm gonna hide.
Alright, guys.
New plan.
Top seven?
I can get top three?
Yeah.
Get some charge rifle kills?
No, you got... just hide.
You're literally the rat.
Rat jam, rat jam.
Oh shit, jam.
You have to go that way.
You can't turn back.
You can't.
Alright, you can't.
Well, now you have to run in front of everybody.
Mother...
Who the fuck can't keep us all around that side?
If you lived for, like, literally one more second, we could've been top...
We got rank six, I think.
This is the best placement we've ever got.
Okay, Mac, in the future, I think, like, if you'd say, like, Doki and Teppo, you'll do this together, I will not listen to you.
What do you mean?
That initial death did not change anything.
We would've still been where we were.
It fucked our rotation!
Our pacing was completely fucked the whole game.
We had to play with nothing.
I had no...
I had no skill for anything.
Oh my god.
Is that Zap?
That's Zap.
I don't think Zap ever had these issues.
Alright, he's kicked off TSM for gatekeeping.
It's okay, we're a vibes team.
We're a vibes team.
What do you mean?
We're still in...
top... top...
Teppo, we got five points.
How are we top anything?
How are we...
Oh, because some people have negative points.
Yeah, that's just two of them.
We're still in top 15.
Otherwise, we'd really be in trouble.
Don't worry.
We're still in top 15.
Wait, we need a new plan, guys.
We need a new plan for a revival mode since kills don't matter.
We just go... We just go zone.
Just play zone.
That's all that matters.
We don't need kills.
We just need zone.
But we just need fast people.
No, we just need to play as if we're in a tournament.
What?
We gotta play like a fucking zone comp.
Yeah, just scan zone and run fast.
We need two fast people and then one zone people.
Okay, Mac, what do you think?
Too fast, one zone.
Just be zooming.
Yeah, I don't know.
What do you mean you don't know?
What do you mean?
I got nothing.
What do you mean you got nothing?
I'm stumped.
I'm truly stumped.
Just pretend that we're two people right now.
Um...
We don't even know what the legends we can play.
That's why I'm stumped.
It's not you guys.
I'm stumped because I don't know about the characters.
Alright, guys.
Just so you guys know, next game is our last game.
Huh?
Is it?
Isn't this our fifth game?
No, this is four.
We have two more.
Feels like an eternity.
Feels like I've been waiting way too long.
It's like...
I was happy for like one second.
Got reminded that the suffering isn't over.
Hey, we doubled our points at this game.
I think.
Almost.
Maybe.
Sort of.
We didn't even get a kill.
We got enough placement points.
We just got placement points.
We got seven points.
That's like barely...
Wait, I thought we got six.
No, we got seventh.
Oh, we got seven.
I said if you lived for like one second longer, we would have been safe.
Oh, wait.
Six and seventh are the exact same points anyway.
Oh, so it doesn't matter.
Yeah, there you go.
Alright, and how many points does that give us?
Three.
We're almost at ten points.
Almost.
We're almost at ten points, guys.
If we break ten points, Mike, we would have done...
Guys, does anyone...
We got second next game and then we double our points.
How many points did we get with Wig?
Guys, I need to know.
How many points did we get with Wig last Twitch Rivals?
She blocked that out of her memory because trauma.
Okay, do you remember how many points we got?
Yeah, but I don't remember anything.
I don't remember what I did yesterday, so...
Oh, yeah, you remember you weren't drunk during ALGS?
I said, I don't think.
Alright.
You don't think.
Maybe I should've asked Max's opinion on Pool B.
Wow!
Alright, that's it.
I'm gonna have to turn on my hacks.
You're gonna turn on your hacks?
Alright.
You're gonna prove me wrong?
You're gonna prove me...
Oh,
that team got fucked.
No, Johnny Price is gonna...
Oh, nope.
Nope.
Oh my god, call up Destroyer.
Yeah.
Yeah, Destroyer.
Hey, can you crash the lobby if we die early?
Yeah, okay.
No, what the fuck?
Why'd you do that when you just installed hacks on your...
Gotta make it not suspicious.
If he crashes the lobby, we have to play longer.
That's even worse.
Alright.
Chat.
Oh, wait.
Wait, is it 6-0?
Nope, that's last game.
Alright.
Two more games.
It's okay, guys.
Are we all having a good time together?
I'm having a great time.
It's all about creating the memories, guys.
Right.
Mac, are you happy I dragged you into this?
And ruin your reputation even more?
What do you mean?
I heard the last game you guys played together was bad, alright?
Reddit's gonna be like, Wow, ClassicAlb switched to M&K and now he's doing worse again.
And then they're gonna see Doki and then they're gonna be like, Oh, wait, never mind.
He's just gonna retire after this rivals.
No, he's gonna see Doki and Tempo.
What do you mean, and Tempo?
What do you mean?
I died because of you!
What do you mean by that?
I should have had some map awareness.
Damn.
My third doesn't listen to the IGL.
So I get punished.
Then I go, Yo, Tempo, kill that guy over there.
Tempo, just fucking in La La Land.
I remembered why I ran away.
Because I was being shot in the side.
Then I said, Tempo, you're gonna get shot in the side up there.
So I ran towards you to get away from the side.
No, you said to slide down to Doki.
You could have ran to me.
We could have killed Rev.
My brain is now remembering what happened.
Okay, guys.
The last Twitch Rivals we got with Wig was 13 points.
So in two games, if we get more than 13 points, then at least we improved.
So in two games, we need what?
Then we improved, guys.
Five more points?
Bro, there's a team 5 that got 11.
Team 13 got 11 points.
Jesus Christ.
How do we see where it is?
Oh, right.
Game 5.
Alright.
Guys.
I still have hope.
Me too.
Despite everything we've been through, I still have hope in us.
I still have hope in us.
It's not over yet.
Okay.
Yeah.
We can get anywhere from 9 to 12th place.
Alright.
We're still good.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Here we go.
I need you to swap some...
Bang fuse.
I need you to swap some of that data on keeping track of score into listening to IGL.
I listen all the time.
I need you to swap some of those...
Alright.
Can people in Temple's chat clip that moment when Mac was like, Temple, can you go help Doki on...
Just what?
Joke's on you.
No one's in my stream.
Suck it.
Can someone go to Temple's stream right now and clip that exact moment?
I'm pretty sure I also don't have VODs on.
You don't have VODs on, did you?
Last time I turned...
Last time I had auto VODs on, someone I was watch-parting had music and then I got like a copy strike thingy.
That's pretty funny.
So then I just made it where I have to publish it after the stream ends.
Oh, you're one of those people.
I don't want to get banned.
Alright guys, we got BangFuse, Octane Wraith, Conduit, Mirage, and Loba.
So we use Fuse for the map, for the beacon.
Longbow L-Star are the guns that give you stuff.
Okay, we play Bang.
We'll play Bang.
I'm already on Fuse.
Okay.
For the beacon scan, right?
So we know where the zone is.
Yeah.
We'll play Fuse, Bang, and we'll Fuse attack people.
And then we'll play...
Alright, B.
Uhh...
So, we're doing Bang, Fuse, and what?
Umm, figuring that out.
I'm trying to cook something, but the colors in my brain are not turning.
So we put...
That is not good.
That is not what I wanted.
Loba, probably.
Okay, so I can do... I guess you're on Bang, and Tempo's on Fuse, and then I'm on Loba.
Yeah.
Alright, that seems hopeful.
I don't know what else to say!
I'm just...
That's...
It's...
It's somewhere.
We're...
We're getting somewhere here.
Alright, and... It'll be fine.
Cuz Tempo can grab two grenades at once out of the Loba.
Yeah.
Okay, do we just need to find a house and live there?
That's all we need to do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we'll find a cozy house.
We'll Loba ult in it.
Tempo will get a million grenades.
I'll grab the evacs.
We'll have nine evac towers, and anyone that comes near us, we're just fucking Fuse ulting our evac.
How do we have nine evac towers?
Cuz we play Loba.
Yeah, I'm gonna be Loba.
Isn't that only three evac towers?
What?
Tempo, you're missing the plot.
I'm confused.
So we're gonna sit in a building, and then we're gonna put a Loba ult down, and we're all gonna grab an evac tower, then we'll drop them, and we'll pick up more evac towers.
So we have nine evacs in our house, yeah.
Got it.
And then someone pulls up, we evac.
Wait, do you know how to do it?
Right, Tempo?
Yeah, just shoot the bang.
What?
Yeah, you shoot the bang smoke with the Fuse ult.
Okay, yeah.
Hey, didn't we have land heights?
No, Tempo.
We landed boardwalk.
Oh, right.
Oh, we need a longbow.
Wait, what are the guns?
It's just...
Elstar longbow.
Okay, it's actually a good...
This isn't bad.
This is doable.
That's a good combo.
Okay.
Yeah, that's really the only guns that matter.
Because, you know, a lot of the other kills don't count.
Apparently.
Oh, wait.
So... Oh, no, wait.
Wait, I'm gonna go pick Loba right now.
Okay.
It's okay.
They won't start the game without me.
I'm important.
Yeah, yeah.
Right?
I also backed out.
Okay.
Yeah, they...
Well, we don't know about that, but like...
Oh, okay.
It's 50-50.
All right.
I believe it.
I believe in us.
I believe.
There's no way.
As long as we beat 13 points, we've like... Tempo and I have technically improved, and we can say that Wig was the problem.
If you think about it.
It's like how...
It's like how, like, you and I...
We won... Wait, no, not...
Not you.
You weren't there.
I won first place in, like, one of your tournaments.
We got first place in one of the...
JP tournaments.
Oh, yeah, we did, too!
Yeah.
Awesome!
And that was without Wig, too.
That was with Link.
Wig, we're not the problem!
Yeah, that was with Link, too.
Yeah!
And he had, like, 300 ping.
Exactly.
We're not the problem, Tempo!
Yeah, it's because Wig keeps taking vacations like this.
That's why.
Guys, it's not toxic, because Wig did this to me in front of 80,000 people.
So...
It is not toxic.
He did the same thing in front of 80,000 people on an official ALGS stream.
So I get to have this.
I...
Alright.
Just ping?
Oh.
Alright.
Tempo, do you have the right character selected?
Yup.
Which is?
I got me Fusey.
Alright.
Just wanna make sure you know who it was.
I'm ready.
I know Matt's paying attention.
Because his, like, reputation's online.
Is it?
We'll see you in competitive Apex Reddit later.
Hey, at least in the end, we all have free money.
True.
Yeah!
That's why I love Twitch Rivals.
Free money!
Yippee!
I love free money.
This is it.
What were you waiting for?
Oh, Google Go.
Ready, ready, ready.
My fucking energy.
Everyone, everyone spam click the ready button.
My energy is dying.
Please.
Here, have a Red Bull.
No.
I haven't drank energy drinks in, like, years.
Wait, does GamerSup count?
GamerSup is an energy drink, man.
But it's powdered.
That's the same.
Yeah.
That's different.
It's powdered.
Oh, no, no.
How can it be energy if it's...
How can it be an energy drink if it's made of powder?
Guys, by the way...
Energy drinks and a powder, too.
By the way, did you guys know I have a GamerSup code?
Did you guys know that?
Where's the Discord cricket sound?
Anyway, guys, if you guys want to try out GamerSup, I have a code, and it's...
If you use DokiBird, you get, like, 15%...
You get 10% off of your GamerSup order.
I'll definitely use that.
Yeah.
Actually, I'm pretty sure I have a cupboard full of that.
A cupboard full of what?
A pantry.
A pantry full of GamerSup.
Wait, really?
Why?
I don't know.
I just got a pantry full of a bunch of protein powder, a bunch of energy drinks, and a bunch of...
You ever just, like, go through one day and take, like, a fraction of a scoop of all of them and put them in one cup?
Oh, just mix all the different brands?
Yeah, the protein powder, the pre-workout, all the... Jesus!
Don't mix it with water, mix it with an energy drink.
Yeah, yeah, mix it with, like, a monster.
No, mix it with alcohol.
What are you talking about?
Oh, no, you got it.
Don't do that!
Guys, don't do that!
That's a joke!
Actually, don't do that!
That's actually a joke!
No, it's actually not that bad.
Do not do what I just said.
Before COVID was a thing, I would mix...
Before COVID was a thing, you take a blue Gatorade...
Yeah?
You get rid of two-thirds of it, then you fill...
then you fill, um...
like, almost two-thirds of it with an energy drink.
Usually it was just Red Bull.
Yeah, oh, Jesus, what the fuck?
Or Monster, doesn't really matter.
You have to fill it with the regular one, because then it'll change that blue into, like, a Hulk green, and then you put two shots of vodka in it.
Jesus, what the fuck, Tempo?
And then that was my super drink called Hulk piss.
Is this what you would drink at school?
No, this was...
this was for volleyball.
Before volleyball matches.
What the fuck?
Tempo's pulling up to play volleyball off the Hulk piss, just like, fucking...
Bro, volleyball goes fucking hard, man.
And then I'd be like, oh yeah, I'm gonna smash this ball right into your head.
What the fuck?
It was so much fun.
You do that for volleyball?
Yeah, that's the super energy drink.
Yeah, the vodka.
Get that vodka in for fucking volleyball, Jesus Christ.
And then, yeah, the mocktail version of that would be with no vodka, but you know.
Dude's going to spike the ball just completely fucking missing.
What do you mean?
I was not a spiker.
I was... my main...
was setting and blocking.
Oh, shit.
You gotta be numb for that.
That's why you put the vodka in.
Exactly.
Sometimes I jump so high, I block with my face.
So you can't feel your face.
So I don't feel it.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
By the way, Booster Weapons, L-Star, and Longbow.
Yeah.
Wait, who am I playing?
What do you mean?
Bangalore.
I forgot.
The Hulk piss unlocked me, man.
The Hawk piss?
It was great.
Noba.
I assume so.
That's why it only works with blue.
It says that one point per member that lands in the designated...
Does that mean each member gets a point?
If they land in a designated location?
Wait, then shouldn't we get three for that dome one?
I guess so.
Yeah, we should have.
Is that how we got three points last time?
No.
Wait, did you not add that?
Yeah, I guess not.
Wait, then we should yell at them to add it.
Oh, okay, somebody...
Oh, minus five!
Who fucked up?
Is it us?
That's another minus five.
I feel like I'm so excited for every minus five.
Minus five.
He's like, oh, minus five!
Who did it?
Minus five.
Team mate?
Oh, Jordan's team.
Jordan, minus five.
Wait, really?
Distraction.
Yo, Jordan said he has ten points.
Minus five puts him at five, which is below us now.
Sucker!
Chill, guys.
We have ten points.
No!
We need him to be minus five!
We moved up a placement and we didn't even have to do anything.
If we minus his points, my team can be above his.
It is.
Let me have this.
And then we can say a VTuber is higher.
No, I shouldn't say that.
My viewership is higher?
No, I can say the VTuber is higher placed.
Oh, the VTuber.
The VTuber community says minus it.
Minus the points.
Minus five.
Alright.
Wait, so like, we should complain about the drops from that dome?
We need those three points.
I don't think they added it.
I think they said they add like the bonus point stuff.
Okay, you gotta be sure about that.
Only the gun bonus points were added.
Okay, should we land on the bonus area?
Like, two of us?
And then...
Oh, is that how people keep getting points?
And then Tempo, you can be our safe line and then...
Is that what we do?
Does it actually say per person?
Yeah, isn't it?
One extra point per member that does their first landing in designated location.
Yeah.
Yeah, so...
So you guys just land there, kill as many people as you can, I'll just be in La La Land.
We don't need to kill anything!
We literally just need to go there and die and then land and then drop on you.
We don't even...
Kills don't matter.
Oh no, find a longbow and then kill someone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mac, take me to Hydra Stadium.
I'm thinking about Boardwalk.
No, we need to land there for the bonus points.
Yeah, we get three bonus points if we land there.
No, we get two because Tempo, you're our safe line.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, Doki should go alone because I have an ability that can shoot people.
No, please don't put too much pressure on me, I don't do so well.
Doki's gonna crack.
I don't do so well.
I believe in you.
She's gonna be like, wait, someone's landing on me, I'm lost, I'm lost, I'm dead.
Alright, where is Heights and Stadium?
This is how people keep getting two free points!
Heights.
Wait, where is our land?
Stadium is over there.
So, is it me or Tempo that's gonna be the safe line?
Uh, both of you can go.
I'll be a safe line.
Wait, you're gonna be a safe line?
Oh, I've been kidnapped.
Okay, you got that.
Wait, what?
Go ahead.
Go over there.
Who's ready to f***?
Okay.
Don't shoot anyone unless you have an L-star or a longbow.
I have so much confidence right now.
Yo, some people are not even gonna be able to fly to here because they're stupid.
I landed on a longbow.
Okay, you gotta live!
I'm gonna go there and just die and then spawn next to you.
Yo, I'm gonna kill someone.
What do you mean?
Okay.
Why do we need kills?
Kills don't f***ing matter!
Kill him with a longbow or an L-star?
Kill him with a longbow.
I'm looking for a longbow.
Yo, suck my...
I don't think Tempo's gonna kill on a longbow.
What the f***?
Yeah, that's right, Q-Bitch!
That's not a longbow, you shit-stain!
I couldn't find a longbow.
Wait, we're... oh, I'm landing on Mac now.
Nice.
Yeah, I'm over here.
You better land on him.
Alright, free point!
Well, why did it not land me on you?
You do not want to land on me.
I know, but why did my plane... well, who does the plane choose?
Because I don't f***ing know.
Is it new or planned?
Nice.
I can't die because there's nobody next to me!
Oh, there he is.
Just find a longbow and shoot someone.
I can't!
There's no longbow!
Oh, I fell.
Oh, I almost fell.
Longbow, longbow, longbow.
Oh, he...
Oh, no!
Okay, good.
That's good.
I'm out.
I'm finally free from this hell.
Thank God.
Hello, I'm back.
Wait, what was... oh, longbow L-star.
Right, right, right.
Wait.
I'm back.
I get to actually be free, but we got two points.
I did it, guys.
Deuce points!
Alright.
Oh, we definitely should have figured that out a lot earlier.
Wait, so, like, you don't get points at all with any other gun but the boosted loader?
Yeah.
That's so dumb.
What?
No, but the longbow and the L-star.
Yeah, yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Like, sorry, not boosted loader.
Boosted gun.
She's calling that the boosted loader.
Okay, it's like boosted gun, so I think boosted loader.
We want the ultimate range, right?
Oh, wait.
You're Loba.
Oh, wait, no, no, no.
You want your throw distance.
Throw distance?
You don't want more loot?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
You wanna throw your thingamajig down so we can...
I don't have it.
I literally just died.
Why didn't you die earlier?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Nobody wanted to kill me.
Here's the 6x.
Actually, I'm taking that if we're fucking running longbow.
Oh, can't climb that.
Oh, no, definitely can't climb that.
Wait, I hear people.
No.
No, you don't.
I think I also hear people.
Oh, no, you don't.
Yo, you know what you do?
Throw a longbow on the ground and bait someone with it.
I mean, you could do that.
Well, actually, I'm...
Since we're running L-star, I'm gonna... Oh, wait.
Did you actually find people?
Yeah, they're here.
I'm not close to you guys.
I'm just sitting on height.
We're fairly close.
One's crossing over here.
I'm fine.
I'm just...
You guys will be fine, right?
Because I'm looting.
I'm looting right now.
They're looking for Tempo.
Why are they looking for him?
Well, they're on you, Tempo.
Throwing a nade at that guy.
Bleed out.
That's not a longbow.
You're a shit stain.
Alright, no kills.
We're good.
Yo, let me find my gun, you cock.
I can't find anything.
I hate looting this.
I'm so confused sometimes.
Not sometimes.
I'm always confused.
Alright, I'm gonna go land, like, far away so I can go find your longbow.
I'm kinda just chilling up here and being annoying.
I don't play this map enough to realize how to loot this.
I knocked one.
Good job.
Oh, with the longbow!
Thresh him!
Oh, I have my ult.
I'm gonna ult here.
Oh, they just got shot in the back.
I got my kill.
Nice!
That's plus one!
Plus one!
And plus two!
There's three kills here.
We're fucking plus three.
There's no L-star.
Oh, there's a longbow!
It's actually the one that he just died with.
Oh my god, I got it.
Let's see...
I'm gonna grab the 4x8.
Oh, I found a longbow!
Me too!
I'm heading over to you!
I got my knock.
I forgot to grab ammo!
Oh, bleed out!
I'm safe!
Bleed out!
I got the points!
Just keep in mind you're on scan when I die.
I know.
That's why I'm leaving.
Yeah, time to just scatter.
We just have to be bastards and take our licks.
Like we just kill someone and just take the lick and reset.
Look what tempo is!
We're so okay.
He's literally not even with us anymore.
He's just gone.
He's just running around.
I'm still looking for a L-star.
Yeah, same.
I'm longbow fucking nemesis.
Wait, me too!
Me too!
Imagine you get a golden longbow.
God, no.
Why does it just force you straight down?
You can't like fly at all.
Where even is the zone?
Yeah, I know.
It's so dumb.
I'mma head to you guys.
We need to find a house.
Shit!
Someone's here.
We gotta figure out where to live.
Found an event.
Tempo found people.
Alright.
I'mma jump in this fire.
Control left!
Left control!
Yeah, that's right.
I got 15, 20 seconds.
I didn't even see that guy.
Well, I'm hiding here until Tempo's back.
Wait, where's my mouse?
Bangalore 2481.
Mac, where's the end zone so we can head there?
I don't know.
Tempo never hit the ring.
Oh.
You're landing on me, Tempo.
No, I'm not.
Yes, you are.
I literally see your thing.
I'm like on the other side of the wall.
That's me.
The green was on me.
Alright, I am going.
No, the green is on you.
He's spawning on you.
He's confused.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
He's just going where he wants to go.
It's like I'm pretty sure I saw the green literally on you.
Oh, that's another team.
Never mind.
Okay, I'm heading to you.
What do you mean?
Wait, how did he get there?
How did he get there?
He just flew over the wall.
I'm moving.
I got movement.
M and K movement.
Oh my god, Monarch, thank you for the raid.
Hey guys.
Amali raided me.
I'm about to headshot someone.
Ooh, I don't need that, but like...
I need that shield.
Here.
I got it.
Alright, where are we going?
We're gonna try to walk into zone.
Tempo, how's it looking over there?
Can we walk in over there?
There's people all over me.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna evac.
Wait, I'm gonna do this.
Wait, actually there's no loot.
I don't think there's loot there.
Ow.
Bad news, you might die.
I might die.
I might not.
Tempo, we need you to be alive because there's a possibility that Mac and I are gonna be fucking dead.
I'm gonna throw a bat on.
They might run at us.
No, 100%.
No, I agree.
Oh, I threw a med kit on because there's a thing being in the wrong spot.
Alright, I'm a piece of shit.
There's definitely no word here because I threw this too.
Yeah, I'm gonna go grab this EVA.
There's no L-Star anywhere.
That's crazy.
There's some bodies over here.
Oh.
TSM banner.
Wait, is this Jordan's body?
Oh, shit.
Do you back him?
Uh-oh.
I'm running.
I'm splitting up.
You have to kill one of us and it's not gonna be...
It's gonna be me and you.
We'll run away from Tempo just in case.
I'm living.
I'm behind somebody.
That's not good.
Alright.
Hey, Tempo's alive.
I wanna live in a house.
I would really like to...
Alright, bleed out.
Bleed out.
Oh, shit.
Never mind.
My hiding spot might be compromised now.
Maybe we group up and go to the houses on the northwest side.
Or northeast side.
Like, towards Yidoki.
There's people living in this house, I think.
I saw smoke.
Yeah, we might want to group up.
I think we have to group up.
No, no, no.
This is good.
There's too many people alive.
Yeah, I'm a little worried that you're landing right next to me.
So...
It's probably okay.
Okay.
Are you sure there's people in the house on the right?
People died right beside me.
Okay, we could try.
I mean... They're now lobo-alting right beside me.
Just show where you're at.
I'll find out if there's people in this house.
Okay.
It got looted.
That got looted.
That got looted, Mike.
There's people right there.
Yeah, there's people on the left.
This one's good.
Okay.
They're just trying to control both.
Alright, I'm heading to you.
You should cue to me.
Cue to me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm cueing to you.
Cue in here.
Cue!
Tempo, you gotta find your way here.
Survive.
Wait, unless the zone pulls to me.
In our fucking bottom floor!
What the fuck?
Where?
Alright, Tempo, live.
Tempo, live!
This is your hope!
They're just inside with no audio.
Tempo, live!
There's a yellow bin on the floor.
43 seconds we are responding.
I'm fucked.
I am dead.
Tempo!
There's a person right here about to loot this.
Spotted a supply bin.
Tempo?
30 seconds, Tempo.
Tempo, just...
Just live for 30... Where's the timer on your death thingy?
No pressure.
29.
We'll count.
We'll give you like 20, 10 second countdowns and stuff.
So like, it's 23.
Do you want me to give you more pressure here?
I can count it down.
Tempo, I don't know if you should move right now.
The zone is not moving yet.
Okay, 10 seconds.
We're gonna land on Tempo and we're gonna play here, I think.
You're gonna land on me?
What the fuck?
You're literally the only person alive!
Of course we can land on you!
Yeah, we have nowhere to go.
There's people everywhere.
Oh, there's someone shooting right there.
Alright.
How are we landing this, man?
We just land on Tempo and we have to shoot everybody to the south.
Is that house taken?
In front of us?
Yes, everything's taken over there.
We need to kill everybody to the south.
That's all we can do.
Yo, there's gold mudba.
Tempo, you need to look at this.
They're fighting over here.
I don't have a...
Tempo's dying.
Tempo's dead.
Yeah, I'm dead.
Where did you die from?
Over here.
I'm taking the yellow bins right now.
I'm gonna try to have them.
I got one of the yellow bins.
I hear them.
I hear them next to me.
I got one of the yellow bins.
Can we come to me?
Yeah, I'm heading over.
Stay with me.
There's hella people behind us.
Okay.
Tempo is healing.
I think we can maybe just waddle in over here, kinda.
Okay.
We're just gonna try to find a cozy little spot to squeak on in.
Right here seems cozy enough.
Okay.
I'm gonna grab these bins.
Stay there for a sec.
I don't...
I don't feel so cozy.
Okay.
And I'm trying to look around.
I think... Come to me.
Come to me.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got a spot.
Come, come, come, come.
Oh my god!
Are we... Did we get real estate?
We're in the pizza store.
Oh my god!
We're in real estate!
We can afford...
We can afford a place to live!
Oh my god.
There's a team in here.
Tempo, Knuckle, fuck them.
They're fighting.
Get Q's in there.
I'm trying to look, but I don't see anybody.
There's people up top peeking too.
Careful.
Don't worry.
The pizza place's glass can block bullets.
I'm playing in the fucking bug.
That's right, bitch!
One HP inside.
Stay alive.
I think we kill this team.
Do I stay alive or...?
No, no.
Just commit to the fight.
It's a fucking rat race from up top.
I'm chasing them.
I don't see it.
It's smoked.
Oh, another team!
Another team's coming!
Another team's pushing in.
He jumped up.
I knocked one up here.
I'm in a different house.
I'm in a different house, Dokie.
I'm gonna grab loot, guys.
Hello.
I believed in him.
Oh, there's a...
Oh my god!
There's a Kraber next to us.
No points for that, though.
Yeah, but...
We need points, yeah.
But it's Kraber.
I'm trying to figure out what to get.
Whoa!
There's a gun shield generator.
There's a bunch of energy bags here.
Okay, we need to find our walk-in.
Okay.
I want to grab that, actually.
There's someone above us.
Oh my god.
Come to me.
Be careful.
We still have to get up here.
Just cue to me, Dokie.
Cue to me.
We're walking into this corner.
We're playing this side of the wall.
Wait, there's people here.
There's people landing.
There's people landing this side.
Where's the audio?
Nice.
Right here.
Pop a bat, Dokie.
Pop a bat.
What the fuck is going on?
There's a guy right here.
I'm blocking that.
You're good.
I can't block that.
It's in your ass.
No, I'm trying to thirst him!
No!
I almost got the thirst!
I'm so sad!
It was so close!
How did that Wraith get over?
I just didn't hear anything.
He's just on my head.
Oh my god.
I almost got the thirst, too.
We almost got the plus one.
That's six points, though.
How did we get six points?
Wait, did you get...
One placement.
Matt got three, I think, longbow kills.
Oh, did you get three longbow kills?
Yeah, they're longbow all-star kills.
That's great.
And then when we dropped on the other team at the very start.
I'm so sad.
I almost got that.
Longbow all-star kill, too.
I could've heard that.
Yeah.
He came out of nowhere.
I didn't see him either.
Oh my god.
We were so close.
We were so close to another seven points.
Wait, but that means...
Temple, how many points did we have last game?
Oh, I have no idea.
Okay.
I zoned out.
I think we're at nine.
We're at nine points?
Yeah.
Now, or like...
Or like, um...
Before.
Whose house teammates again?
Isn't the house teammates a TSM...
One of the TSM players?
Yep.
And...
Wait a minute.
You know the Dome game?
Yeah.
Did we die early?
What do you mean?
With one kill?
Yeah, we died with one kill, yeah.
And we died early?
What do you mean by early?
We landed in Dome.
And survived in Dome.
Like, did we get any placement points?
No.
We got one, I think.
Plus one.
I don't actually know.
Actually, no.
We died really early, yeah.
Okay, so I think that adds it in.
Okay.
Are we gone?
Where are we?
What did we get?
We're at 15.
We beat our record!
We did it!
My career is saved.
We're better than Quake!
We did it!
Now we can cruise.
Now that we know we beat our record.
Oh my god, I'm so proud of us!
Now we double our points this next game.
Okay, that's a little bit too much confidence.
We need second with six kills.
It's a bit too much confidence.
The best placement we got was top six.
Top seven.
Because you rat it.
Top two is imminent.
I mean, if we don't die early, maybe.
Maybe if we find a house early.
And a zone.
I wonder...
I wonder if Hal...
Did Hal die?
Or is his team okay?
I have no idea.
Because that howling was pretty bad.
I hope they put the minus five to...
I hope reps got the minus five.
Wait.
They said they were at what?
Ten points?
Yeah, they were ten points, so he should have five points.
People should not get special treatment.
Timmy got minus five on the first game.
That's all I'm saying.
Oh, Jordan is with Clara.
Oh.
Who?
They're at 18.
So if you minus five, they're at 13.
And if you plus R6, we're at 15.
So...
I mean, they could have placed higher.
They just needed to pick right.
Ahem.
Oh my god, this is a tense game.
ALGS.
We just gotta make sure we don't get minus five.
And then...
This will be okay.
It's okay.
Next game.
Oh my god, how many nades are they throwing at this team?
Oh, that
rat.
That rat lived for a long time.
What the fuck is going on?
Madness might win here.
Oh no, never mind.
No, I think that's...
That team has like 200,000 nades.
Oh, he's gonna explode to that nade.
He's gonna get fucking sent to another planet.
I was gonna say.
That team has 200,000 nades.
I don't think he's gonna live.
Madness team really used all their nades last game.
Or last fight.
Ahem.
We have our Apex champions.
Team 13.
Alright.
Let's see.
I wanna see where Hal placed.
To get that reaction.
Oh no.
What made him react like that?
Wait, where is...
Oh, top 10.
It's not that bad.
They got seven kills.
That's not that bad.
Oh no.
Jordan got a bunch of placement points.
So that minus five does not help us.
Wait, which one is true?
Jordan is...
They got team three.
Holy shit, they got ten kills!
Which might not matter.
I don't know.
Tech discord going to new lobby.
Okay.
Alright, pee break.
You pee so much.
Oh, new lobby time.
He's been peeing every game.
Like, that's...
That's not healthy, is it?
It's probably healthy.
Is it healthy?
Peeing, like, every 20 minutes?
Bro, just be pissing, man.
He's been pissing, man.
I don't think that's...
I don't think that's it.
Depends how much water he's drinking, I guess.
I don't know.
It means you are hydrated.
But every 20 minutes?
Every 20 to 30 minutes?
Hey man, you want to be dehydrated?
That's up to you.
Like, I hydrate, but not every 20 to 30 minutes.
Temple's just locked in on the hydration, I guess.
I guess so.
I guess that's how he does his number counting thing.
He stays...
The more hydrated he is, the better he counts.
Alright.
Or it's all that Hulk piss.
Oh, that's true.
The Hulk piss is just running through him.
Guys, I have a new plan.
Oh, here we go.
This is our last game.
Are we still going dome?
Yeah.
Okay, new plan.
We have a support.
Wait, does dome get a crafter?
We don't even know what characters we're allowed to play yet.
Yeah, we do.
Yeah, they just posted it.
Oh yeah, you know what?
You're right.
I'll shut up.
New plan.
Does dome get a crafter?
Do you know?
Yeah, it can.
It can?
You mean it's not guaranteed?
No crafters are guaranteed.
Oh, interesting.
Alright.
But you should know this, Tempo.
Why should I know that?
I'm not playing.
You organize the screens and stuff.
So the plan is...
We grab a support.
Two of us land in Skyhook or Frag.
Get the two free bonus points.
If we kill someone, great.
If we don't, doesn't matter.
Because then the third person can craft us back at dome.
And boom.
We start the game with two points.
Hmm.
Five head.
But what if we don't have crafter?
If we get a crafter?
Then yeah, go for it.
Oh, you're right.
We can choose after.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come on, crafter.
But who are the ones that are landing there?
I think we play...
Gibby...
Watson...
Oh, I like Watson.
And...
Maggie.
Okay.
And what are you playing, Mac?
I will play Gibby.
Okay, and then I'll play Maggie then.
Yeah.
It's a Watson that blends into World's Edge.
Alright.
Oh, I look like lava.
Where is she?
I always forget where she is on the screen.
Alright, new code.
New code.
Last game, guys.
Last game.
I need less shiny.
So, is Tempo our safe line again?
Or are you our safe line, Mac?
Yeah, Tempo is.
Tempo is?
So I'm landing with you?
I want to grief people.
No, Tempo.
You're Watson.
You're going to stay in the dome.
You're going to be a...
If there's a crafter.
Oh, wait.
Just in that small circle.
What?
You have to land in the skyhook.
I mean, we could do Fragment West.
You have to land right in the middle.
Yeah, but we could do Fragment West.
It's easier.
Wait a minute.
That's not even Fragment West.
That's just Fragment.
What?
There's no more West.
It's just Fragment.
Five head plan, guys.
Two free points.
Let's do it.
Alright.
Yippee.
I'm so ready.
I'm so, I'm so ready.
We going Mon.
We going Mon if go Frag West.
I'll cry later.
I'm so ready.
I don't even know who that is.
This is it.
The final countdown.
The final game.
And then we'll be free.
Oh, wait.
They actually put minus points.
Wait, they did?
Yeah!
Wait.
How do you know?
12, 9.
How do you know they got minus 5?
Because I'm looking at the scores and there's a team that has negative 2 in one of the games.
Oh!
Rampage, triple take this game.
Wait, in one of the games?
Like the last game or like the beginning?
The last game wasn't added yet.
One of the beginning games, yeah.
Oh, okay.
One of the beginning games.
Okay, I was going to be like, oh my god, someone's still 90.
Wait.
Rampage, triple take?
Girls 18th place?
Are we 20th place?
19.
Okay, can we do better than girls team?
Wait, if we get two points here?
If we get two points here?
Wait, where are we in?
We're 19th.
Guys, that's the same placement as Wig, guys.
We just need... guys, guys.
Last game wasn't included, that's why.
Oh, okay.
So it could be better or it could be worse.
Guys, I just want to be better than the team above me.
I'm fiving.
And apparently the team above me is girls team.
So I just...
How far is the gap?
Is it durable tempo if we win?
If we land on frag, that's two points.
Yeah, but they're going to land on frag too.
That's not what I asked.
They might not know.
Wait, who's 20th place?
And we're 19th.
We're the fucking 20th.
How far are we from top 10?
It's one of the teams that got negative five.
Wait, Timmy?
No, Julie's team.
Oh, Julie's team, sure.
Okay, we have to be above sure force team.
That's all I care about.
That's literally all I care about.
We have to be above sure force team.
I need a gloat.
We got three points for Hotspot game two.
We got one point for Hotspot.
Wait, what did we do last game?
Wait, they gave negative five points?
Jeez, how many...
Wait, there's more than one.
I know like three teams.
Why did three teams get negative five last game?
Wait, one?
And we're still...
This is brilliant.
We are trying our best.
We are trying our best to make sure everyone gets the negatives that they deserve.
Alright, come on, give us Crafter.
Give us Crafter.
Money, money, money.
Yeah, we're all here.
Ready up.
I hate these like in-betweens every...
I feel like...
I don't know this Twitch rivals thing, but I hate it when they take like 20 fucking years to start a game in between.
You think everyone's been doing this The entire time, in the normal games, two people landing and then crafting?
No, because there's no fucking hot drop.
No, there is hot drop.
No, I meant like extra points.
Oh, you mean the extra points.
The bonus points for the landing.
We just only figured it out at game 6?
Yes, because we're stupid.
This is not the team that's going to win.
This is the Vibes team.
The Vibes team don't think.
This is why I don't want to be captain.
Literally when I was picking, I was just like, who do I know?
And I know I vibe well.
Because I was like, I don't know who these people are.
I put the dead fly in one of the empty drinks.
Why?
I don't have a garbage can here.
Why would you put it in your drink?
Because it was empty.
Oh, okay.
And I was going to throw it out.
But then I forgot and I almost drank it.
Oh my god.
This is why you don't put it in empty.
Because I don't put it in the can.
I drank it and I was like, wait a minute.
Did I put the fly in there?
And I was like, oh wait.
Someone said extra protein.
Alright, so let me move these cans away so I don't accidentally drink it.
How many cans do you have there?
I heard...
I'm at three cans.
Red Bull?
Yeah.
Bro, what the fuck?
I'm locked.
No, you are not.
I'm locked in.
After three cans.
Wait, ready?
I gotta move this over here.
Maybe this is why you're peeing every fucking 20 to 30 minutes.
Your fucking poor kidneys, man.
I'm locked in.
Wait, kidneys?
Isn't that alcohol?
At least one person from each team...
Wait, one person from each team has to hit ready to signify we're ready?
I wasn't even...
I didn't notice that.
I was always ready.
Don't worry guys, I got our team readied up.
I don't.
What the fuck?
Who isn't readied?
Everybody's readied.
Yeah.
Everyone has... well, you said only one person needs to readied.
So what are you waiting for?
We're all good.
Click the go button?
I'm Mad Maggie, right?
Come on, crafter!
Gimme, gimme, crafter, gimme.
We're not even in game.
Yeah, you're Maggie.
Yay.
Where are the guns this time?
Rampage triple take?
Oh!
I'll get the triple take.
I hope the bottom five teams get a minus five.
But not us.
Do all of us have our characters readied?
Yup.
What's your character, Tempo?
Tempo?
What's your character?
I'm scared.
Wait, 14th place?
Tempo has 18 points.
Wait.
How far away is top ten?
I asked like four times, Tempo ignored me and I gave up.
And he was like, I'm locked in.
Alright guys, can you hear me?
Yeah, what happened?
I'm ready.
Tempo, how far is top ten?
I hate this guy.
Wait, I'm refreshing.
I actually hate this guy.
The points aren't refreshed yet, we don't know.
Game five is not ready yet.
We got this.
Tempo, what are you playing?
I forgot.
You wanna play a little game?
Huh?
He's playing Wacom.
I think.
Alright, he's locked.
Where's me?
Alright.
There he is on Wacom.
I'm a little worried.
Oh, there he goes.
Tempo is locked into a different dimension.
I am.
Look.
Look what?
If you open the stream, you can see.
How locked I am.
Oh, no.
I don't know if I want to at this point.
We have a crafter.
Land there.
Land there and fuck them.
What the fuck, Tempo?
How are you gonna see?
Yo, donkey.
Peel, peel, peel.
I'm fucked.
I'm not gonna make it.
Oh, no.
Why did you click?
I was trying to fucking...
It's fine.
Do what you wanna do.
I'll handle business and money.
Why, Tempo?
I was jump leader and I had to fucking give away the jump leader.
How are you jump leader?
Don't worry.
I'm handling business.
Why did you click?
I couldn't fucking separate myself.
I got triple landed on.
I'm sent to Narnia.
Let's go, baby.
Okay, at least like...
Oh, shit.
Hang on.
I'm gonna try to get a kill.
I got you.
I'm ready.
He's ready.
He's locked in the craft.
Alright,
at least we got that plus one.
Okay.
Alright.
I crafted a bat.
Are you real, Tempo?
No, he crafted it.
Okay.
Did you see his stream?
No.
Okay, open his stream while you're respawning.
I'll look after.
I gotta stay locked in this game.
Bro, he doesn't have Vons on.
Yeah, yeah.
I had to wait for him to turn it off.
Wait, what do you mean?
I need a triple take, guys.
You guys find one.
I need a rampage.
Wait, where did it go?
Isn't it...
Oh yeah, it's triple take rampage.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Hmm.
I don't think we're gonna...
Yo, we got one point.
What do you mean?
Why are you doubting?
We're gonna get the top 10 off this game.
Okay.
Locked, cocked, and ready to go.
Tempo can barely see, like...
see right now with what he's wearing.
What do you mean?
Is he wearing the fucking Batman mask?
I found a rampage.
He has a Batman mask?
Oh, Batman.
Okay, I'll just say that, like...
He has more than...
Mac, he has more than one mask.
Is he wearing like a...
If I open this stream and he's wearing like a Gimp mask or something, bro?
I mean...
You could say that.
Okay.
We lost for like two seconds.
I see team in stacks and they're fighting someone else.
Sounds like a Gimp mask.
If you find me, like, two Mozabs, I can give you... give somebody two P20s.
Ooh.
What the fuck?
Did you see it?
He is locked in.
That's what I'm saying.
I was gonna fucking see anything.
Wait, wait.
Stacks might fly on us.
I'm watching.
Alright.
Why are there no rampages here, man?
Does anyone wanna take my P20?
Double P20?
No.
I have a gold light mag.
Let's go get the stream console.
Okay.
I have a gold light mag.
Does anyone want that?
No.
There's...
There's still fighting in stacks, so we should be okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
We just hit this.
It'll be fine.
They won't see us.
I mean, maybe we can just, like, get involved and get in some ass.
No, no, no.
Let's not.
Let's not get involved.
Let's not get involved, guys.
Remember, every time... every time we got involved, we got fucked over.
Mac, Mac, every time we got involved, we got fucked over.
I can kill a Wattson here.
Are they on the roof?
Yeah, right here.
Mmm, okay.
Come on, Kobe.
Why are you...
I can't stand this guy.
Alright, let's walk away.
Tempo gave us away.
This is what I was saying.
We could have 3-2-1-1 in the back and Tempo's like, fuck it, dude, throw the grenade.
Like, bro, you're actually just a Borderlands character.
Didn't they have a Wattson on?
Yeah, they did.
He threw it right into their gen and did nothing.
Oh, they had a gen?
Yeah!
I was looking at it!
They were, like, fenced up with gens and everything, bro.
Where do we go?
This unfortunate series of events.
Tempo...
This guy's actually just a Borderlands character.
Joke's on you.
I don't know what that is supposed to mean.
What do you mean?
Do you not know Borderlands?
No.
The movie that failed?
I've never played that game.
You've heard of that game, right?
Yeah.
Okay, alright.
I still don't know what it's about.
It's your kind of humor.
You would like it.
That's the best way we can describe it.
Yeah.
Where are we going, Max?
Towards zone.
We're gonna go grab this assault bin and this Evo.
Maybe the support bin.
Didn't somebody land there?
Yeah, but they've probably fucked off.
If they haven't, then I mean...
Yeah.
It is what it is.
Okay.
It'll be fine.
Don't think too much.
We're a tanking team anyway, so you're right.
Oh, Rampage!
I got one.
Yeah, you might want one.
Yeah, I'll get it now.
I'm ready as well.
Alright.
Where the fuck are the triple takes?
Keep moving, gentlemen.
Keep moving.
Oh, okay.
We're moving.
We're schmoving.
I'm with Tempo, so like...
If I die, he dies too.
That's probably for the best.
For yourself.
It's everyone for themselves.
You think you would live longer as a rat?
Yeah.
You know we should do that!
Tempo now would fuck off the different direction and you fuck off to the right and see who lives longer.
I'm just hurting rats right now.
I want that.
We'll get this ring console.
We'll grab the Evo.
We'll have a great time.
I like this.
Nice.
Ideas.
Alright, Tempo.
Scan, scan, scan.
Oh, if we get top thermal with charge rifle?
Yup, yup.
If top thermal is open, that's where we're going.
We grab this Evo Do you think it's open?
Fuck no, but it might be.
My expectations of being open are zero, but if it is Tempo, we're going.
That's very confident.
How are you guys on purple?
Because we did our stuff.
We did our job.
I'm 20 off.
How did this happen?
Because I did damage to people.
Well, I didn't do damage, but I did my job.
Just kidding.
Do I get big drill or drill singer?
Drill singer.
Okay.
The gain of riot drill charge.
Okay, I think we just play here.
Can you fence that choke up, Tempo?
And just pay attention to it.
Fencing?
Yeah, put fences on the far side too.
Show presence.
And then we play up here.
Okay.
Are people in there?
Yeah, they are.
I see them.
Okay.
I'm heading over to...
Which way do you want me to look at?
You can look down there for kills.
Where's there?
You can look towards thermal.
Thermal?
Okay.
Should I just gen up that building or no?
No, no.
We're not playing the building.
Look at the map, bro.
Come over here.
We're not with you, Tempo.
There's a cat there.
Can I shoot them?
Yeah, shoot.
There's a team entry right now.
Okay.
Tempo, come to me and put Gen over here, Tempo.
This team's going this way.
They're trying to wrap.
Whoa!
He has a longbow.
What are you doing?
That's not in the required guns.
I think this corner's best, right?
This team's trying to walk up.
You want us to come to you?
Yeah, yeah.
We're gonna have to hold this team.
Okay.
I'm heading over to the map.
Just play where you're at, but look towards true.
You have to make sure they don't walk up over here.
You gonna play where you are or where I'm at?
Kinda towards me.
Okay, I'm heading to your direction then.
They're going under me.
I killed one, I killed one.
I'm here with you.
I'm not.
I'm gonna stay here.
Yeah, they're underneath me.
I don't know if they have golden hawk.
I think that they already have.
Yeah, I don't think we should drop down.
No, no.
Tempo?
We're good, we're good.
So we're playing this hill spot.
Our next spot, we're gonna play for the jungle gyms down on the lower ground.
Can you guys stay up here?
Just keep an eye out.
I'm just making sure our backs are clear.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Wait, there's people here!
Where?
In tree?
Or under you?
Okay, we can't let them walk up.
Oh, they're nading me, they're nading me.
Yeah, they're gonna try to...
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Swap about, you're good.
I'm watching this side.
I think they went under.
Yeah, I think that was the tunnel team just trying to nade you.
No, no, they were far.
They weren't in tunnel.
They ran from a different direction.
They came from here.
Let's see...
I'm heading back to you.
Our backs are cleared!
Okay, Tempo.
Can someone still come up?
Yeah, they can.
Tempo, come here and just watch our back.
Just watch it from here.
Like this.
Play by this rock and just stare into the zone.
I need to go see how much space we have.
Where do we go after this?
I want to see if we can play here.
I think we can play there and just shoot down.
Should we take it early now?
No, I'm trying to figure that out.
I think there's a team here.
We can play here.
We can play all this shit, I think.
We need to make sure that the Tracks team, the team that's under, doesn't come our way.
So we have to push them into the buildings and then make a big fight happen here.
Tracks team just walked out.
Let me know when to come.
They're good.
The Tracks team walked out, so they're playing underneath in Thermal now.
One of you, Doki, can you look at this?
Yeah, I'll look.
I'll go back then.
I'm going to play at our spot right now.
I think our spot's good.
Enough.
There's nobody on the roof.
They're in their building.
Oh, he's right here.
I think he's looking at an ash hall or something.
Yeah.
Oh, they're right here.
Behind the...
Yeah, we just hold them.
Blue armor?
We need to make them go to the gondolas.
I don't think anyone's coming on my side.
We have 10 seconds.
Someone's evac'ing.
Position revealed by Ash.
Yeah, it's the low ground guy that I just killed.
Oh, okay.
I was like, what?
They're going to fly over now.
Yeah, yeah, flying in on me.
One, two.
Come to me.
Just run off that.
Just run to me.
I'm trying to.
I hit one.
But I might not make it.
Just get to me.
Get to me.
Come, come, come.
I might be dead now.
They're going to try to send.
I'm bubbling here.
We're good.
A ball's going to hit our bub.
Oh, fuck.
What?
I can't see.
I got hit.
I got one.
One's dead.
You have to live.
I'm dead.
How did the team on height that was shooting me doesn't just shoot them?
Why do we get fucked?
Because we are that unlucky.
Oh, it's Hal.
Wait, who?
The one that killed us?
Yeah.
Is it?
No, he's a giggle.
I'm at the high ground.
I'm at the center.
Never mind, it isn't.
The center team is...
This is madness.
Did they survive?
Yeah, they did.
One dead.
Oh my god, that's fucked.
They actually survived.
Oh, I didn't know they had Maggie.
Otherwise, I wouldn't have domed there.
Wait, does the Maggie...
Oh yeah, the Maggie destroys the fucking dome.
Yeah, I didn't know they had a Maggie.
Yeah, that's unlucky.
Okay, as long as I'm higher placed than sure for, that's all that matters to me.
Okay, wait.
I'm dead right now, so I can check.
No!
He's still alive!
With kills?
Let me check.
Yes!
With two kills!
He's still alive!
No!
No, he's gonna...
He's actually gonna make it.
Alright, at least we broke one of our goals, which was...
The other goal that I wanted was to beat our score with Wig, so at least we had that.
It's so Jover.
Wait, I thought you got a kill with a rampage.
No, I thirsted a guy.
He got knocked.
But then how did our position got revealed by Ash?
Because the guy...
Like, if you thirst somebody, they can scan the box.
Oh, you thirsted somebody.
Oh...
Thirsting gets you scanned?
What the fuck?
Yeah, it's not thirsting.
I thought it scans the person who you kill.
Not like the person you thirst.
That's weird.
Wait, how did that arc not hit him?
What's going on?
Whoa.
That poor guy.
Wait, he started crafting?
What the fuck was he crafting?
Teammates.
Yeah, but no, he had teammates.
Oh my god.
That was unlucky.
That they landed on us.
Team 14?
No, he's team 15.
Surefour is team 15.
Can't believe we didn't find a single triple take either, which is cursed for us.
I was running double rampage.
Yeah, we found 200 rampages but like zero triple takes.
But to be fair, I feel like triple takes have a lower spawn rate in general.
This is team 15.
Please don't let them have top 10.
Please.
There's hope.
Clearly hope.
Wait, if they get top 10 are they passed?
Wait, team 15 got 11.
But they had two points.
That's two points.
That's one point.
So they got three.
They got three?
Yeah.
How many points did they have?
Unless they used the gun to get that kill.
How many points is that?
Like what points were they for 20th?
That gets them to eight, I think.
Yeah, that gets them to eight.
And then how many points did we have?
Twelve.
Twelve?
Thirteen.
Oh, please, please.
With the plus two that we just got?
Fourteen.
Or plus one.
Sorry, plus one.
Yeah, plus two that we just got.
Okay.
Oh, please.
Plus three, but you didn't land with him.
I literally was at to get the jump master away.
And then you pressed jump.
Instantly.
I couldn't detach.
Detach.
You literally jumped instantly the moment I gave you jump leader.
I was trying to fucking separate myself from you guys.
Oh, I thought Matt gave it to me so that I could fly away.
No, I was jump leader.
Oh.
Top thermal.
Oh my god.
Alright, next time I'm gonna be like, please never make me a captain ever again.
Alright.
It would've been nice to be told that I got captain.
It really would've been.
I could've been like, no, I wanna be a player.
I'd rather be like chosen instead of a captain.
No chat, you don't understand.
I got in last minute.
Like, when they- Wait, did you actually get in last minute?
Yes, you were in there before I was in it.
I was looking at it.
I literally got in when 50 players were already confirmed.
That's why I was like, how the fuck was I captain?
That's why I was so confused.
No, they never make me captain for Apex.
They never.
But they also didn't even tell me.
I would've been like, I don't wanna be captain.
Because the thing is, chat, it's not fair because some of the captains are like considered pool A players, but I'm not pool A.
I'm like pool B.
Which is where Tempo is in.
What do you mean?
Pool B was the pro player.
Oh, so you wanna be in pool B so that you can't be in the same team as Tempo again.
That's fucked up.
No, it's more so don't invite Doki to anymore Twitch Rivals.
Teams are like super imbalanced because Twitch Rivals will not listen to you, they listen to me.
Don't invite Doki anymore, alright.
It's real serious, the real serious voice.
Well guess what?
Joke's on you.
I applied to work at Twitch too.
You applied to work at leaving TSM?
No, I was planning to do both.
Haven't you heard those people who like do 4 4 remote jobs at the same time?
That's my plan.
Yeah, but if you work at Twitch the Twitch staff I work with has seniority over you.
So it doesn't matter what you want.
I applied for Twitch, I applied for EA and my plan is to work for EA, Twitch and TSM and Falcons all at the same time.
Bro, you're fucking gonna...
Is that why you're living with Hal?
Yeah, is that why?
Does that why you slid into Hal's DMs?
And now I live with him?
And now you're his live-in maid?
Uh oh.
Is this why?
Is this like the trade-off?
You're his live-in maid and he gets you into Falcon?
You don't even get paid?
You just...
You want the oil money?
Alright, come on.
Come on.
Points, points.
You're into that oil money.
You got three points, apparently.
The Sureforce team.
I just need to know Sureforce points.
That's all I want.
But GG's, guys.
GG's.
What a journey today that we had.
What a fucking journey.
Woo, that was fun.
GG's.
GG's, guys.
Yeah.
We'll do it again.
Challenger circuit year five, right?
Doki?
Okay, Wig just has to be able to... Wig is so fucking busy.
I don't...
All I'm seeing is that...
Let's move this over here.
This over here.
Alright, what are the points?
Those are the points so far.
Without game...
The thing is, I don't...
Okay, wait.
Something got added somewhere.
Something got added?
I think...
I think they already added the points from the hot spots.
I mean, they better.
Like, they should.
But now they just need to add... wait.
Now they just need to add the points from the games.
They just need to add points for game six.
Like, from the actual, like, gameplay.
Yeah.
Do we get a point for our placement?
I got a plus one.
No?
What did we place?
Oh, I have no clue.
I don't even know what the placement points are.
What the fuck?
How the fuck?
Wait!
Surefire's team got two minus fives.
How?
Wait!
What?
Wait, why did they get two minus fives?
How the fuck did you... how the fuck...
Did they mess up twice?
Did you guys get two minus fives?
Yes, chat!
He got two... he was... he has minus seven from, like...
Minus five and minus five in game two and five.
How the fuck was that possible?
That's actually impressive.
That's not actually...
That's actually very impressive.
I'm actually...
Oh, thank god!
What?
It's refreshed?
Wait, I'm trying...
It's not refreshed?
Oh my god, please.
I'm scared.
Wait, why does this order thingy keep changing?
It's changing a lot and I'm scared.
Sorry.
I don't know.
I'm scared.
That's the thing.
I can't tell.
I just...
I just need to know.
Surely we got, like, fifteenth.
No, we did not.
I'm very confident to say that we did not.
No.
You know why I really want to be sure for it?
It's updated.
Oh wait, it's not updated.
It's not.
You know why I really want to get fucking better than sure for it?
Because he literally messaged me and said you're going to get freaking owned before our tournament started.
Wait, actually?
Send him a screenshot.
He literally was like you're going to get freaking owned before the tournament even started.
Wait, it's updated?
It keeps changing.
He said we picked the wrong characters twice.
Yeah, that's right.
Every time, yeah.
Every time you...
No, I don't know how...
When your team picked the wrong character.
Oh my god.
descriptions
watching You should pick me over ten points.
Why?
You would have got minus ten points again.
If he wasn't the one...
He wasn't the one that picked the wrong character.
overturned See I made sure we were all on the right character beforehand.
That was my job.
cookie bar Corya
Okay, that one's done.
Alright, we're back.
Updated?
Oh, it's updated?
I think it's perma-updated.
Man, that's a lot of points.
I don't think it's updated, man.
I mean, just add it up yourselves, because they have the...
I refreshed it.
No, just add these numbers if they're not accurate.
You can't be bothered now.
Yeah, it's too late.
Too much work.
What do you mean?
You were so into the numbers before!
How did you stop being into numbers?
My Red Bull ran out.
You did okay.
I'm like, no.
Okay, don't worry, I got this.
It's alright.
I'm happy.
If we did get more than points than Surefour, I'm happy.
We did.
I added them.
Oh thank god, that's fucking karma.
Now screenshot it and send it to Surefour and say, suck it.
Wait, how much did we get?
Where are we?
We're at 19th.
But it's higher than Surefour's team, and that's all that's left.
I got 20th?
Yeah.
Fucking slammed.
Wait, isn't Deeds on their team?
Isn't Deeds on Surefour's team?
Guys, I don't think... we can't really celebrate too much about it, because they did get minus 10.
Guys.
Oh.
But like, yeah!
Fuck you!
That means we just played smarter.
We just played smarter, that's right.
We had a couple of handicaps going in, so like...
In the end, everyone got the same amount of points.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
From 11th to... what?
11th to 20th?
13th to 20th?
I think?
Something like that?
Yeah.
Why did you message me if they didn't get minus 10, they would've passed us?
You weren't supposed to read that out loud!
I think everybody could easily insinuate that that was what's gonna happen.
No one needs to know.
No one needs to know anything.
Everybody knew already!
It wasn't a secret!
Hey, wait a minute.
Timmy's team didn't get minus 5.
What favor is this?
Did they actually not get minus 5?
Unless they got so many points that... Oh, wait.
Maybe they did.
I don't know.
What team are they?
It doesn't matter.
In the end, they were not as coordinated as us, because we picked it correctly.
Like, how do you fuck up twice, you know?
Tim Tam is Janie.
All I'm saying is...
How could they fuck it up twice?
Like, one time, that's understandable, but two in...
two times?
That do be true.
So with so much intermission in between, that was enough time to pick your legend.
So, in the end, it's not our fault.
In the end, it's not our fault.
We...
We did it.
We fucking did it, guys.
GG's, everybody.
GG's.
I gotta go play ranked.
GG's, guys.
Good luck in ranked.
I gotta do my second stream.
We'll see you next Twitch Rivals, and we will increase our position by two.
Alright, I'm gonna see...
I'm gonna be in pool B, so we're not gonna see each other.
You know what the next Twitch Rivals will be?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll be the captain.
I'll grab you, dude.
We'll be there in person.
We'll be in the same pool.
It'll be fine.
Oh, okay.
So you'll grab me.
Oh, I see.
Yo, Mac, you know what?
You know what this is?
You know those league games where someone... where your teammate calls you shit, and then you match up against them next match, and then you beat them?
That's right, Doki.
You ready?
Yeah, that's right.
I'm okay.
If you match listen to the next IGL, I would be very impressed.
By the way, the next one is probably in person.
Is it actually at TwitchCon?
I would assume that the next one is at TwitchCon if they have an Apex one, right?
Yeah, but are they gonna have an Apex one?
There's no way they're gonna have one in between now and, what, September?
I don't know.
They could.
There's nothing stopping them.
And you guys, you know what?
You should ask your Twitch Rivals person, and then tell them to run another one, so you can get the salty run back.
The salty run back?
Yeah, that's what it's called in League.
The salty run back.
I thought you're the one that wants the salty run back.
I don't care either way.
You're the one that said he's gonna pick you over me.
I didn't say that.
Max said he's gonna pick me back with the one that said that.
He's like, don't worry, I'll get you on my team.
Yeah, keep this tempo guy in the same pool.
You didn't...
You still are not listening to him.
Wait.
I have no idea what we're talking about.
I'm confused now.
I'm sorry.
He's fine.
I'm confused.
90% of this is Max trying to tell you something, and you don't know what it is.
See?
He doesn't understand the comms.
He doesn't understand what I'm saying.
He's just lost.
He's Jigsaw though.
He's Jigsaw.
Yeah.
Do you wanna play a little game?
Oh, bro.
Oh, yeah.
Chi-chis, guys.
Alright, I will see you guys next time.
Yeah, I'll see you on the other team.
Later.
Chi-chis, everybody.
Chi-chis.
Bye.
That was fun.
I had a great time.
This was...
I knew going in, I was like, this is gonna be a Vibes team.
I was like, you know what?
I aimed for Vibes over, like, placement because I just wanted to chill and just have fun.
I didn't wanna try too hard.
Cause, like, it's always a gamble.
It's always a gamble cause what if, like, the chemistry don't work?
And, like, the chemistry doesn't work and, like, I have to deal with awkward...
Cause the thing is, I knew the stream was gonna be, like, four hours.
I knew it was gonna be four fucking hours.
So I was like, I don't really wanna...
I don't really wanna fucking be in four hours with a team I might not Vibe with.
And, like, um...
And I was just like, yeah, I'm just gonna... I'm just gonna chill.
I want people that I know I'll have fun like, just playing with and just Vibing even when we don't do well.
Cause, like, that's something I like...
I like to do.
Cause, like, I don't take it as seriously anymore.
Cause, like, I don't...
For me, personally, like...
Cause I knew I was captain.
I was captain and, like, the thing that was fucked is I was, like, really mad.
Like, not mad but, like, annoyed about because, like, I didn't really wanna be captain was because, like, captains are usually, like, other pro players.
They're usually, like, other pros or, like, other like, Apex... like, actual Apex players that, like, play this game every single day and are, like, high ranked and stuff.
Cause they're, like, pro... like, female pro players and... that were captains and, like, other... like, it was all, like, Apex players that play this game 24-7 now.
And, obviously, I don't cause I'm busy with other stuff.
Like, I have other stuff right now to do.
I'm more of a variety.
Um...
So, I was, like, really, like...
I felt, like, oh, man.
My team, no matter what... um...
No matter what, we're, like, at a huge disadvantage because, like, it's basically, uh... um... it's basically like, you know, I'm not supposed to be a captain, but I am.
I'm supposed to be in Pool B, not fucking captain spot.
So, that's why I was, like, uh...
Alright, I'm just gonna pick people I vibe with cause it was, like, like I said, I was, like, okay, I do what.
I was, like, oh, I know Zap's really good, but, like, I don't know what his personality is like.
I've never played with Zap before.
I know he's on TSM.
But I've never played with him before.
But I played with Mac.
So, I went with Mac cause I was, like, oh, I played with Mac and I know, like, he and I vibe really well.
And then I was, like, and then there was, like, six other players left.
And I was, like, I don't know who these six other players are.
I'm gonna pick Tempo cause I know, like, he's, like, he's just fun to just, like, like, fuck around with.
Some, like, just banter with.
So, yeah.
Cause I looked at the six players.
I was, like, who are... I don't know who any of these people are.
Um, yeah.
Anyway, it was a great time.
I do have another stream.
I'm gonna... I'll...
delay it 30 minutes, the second stream.
Only because, like, I do need a rest.
I had no... I just want you guys to know, I had literally zero break time from... since the convention in the morning.
That's why I was, like, my energy was dying out at the end.
Because this was my schedule.
It was, like, 7 AM, uh, panel, like, tech rehearsal, getting to the apartment, uh, tech rehearsal, um, pan, uh, getting, uh, getting, uh, breakfast real quick, uh, uh, panel, straight to the meet and greet, and then I found out at the end of the meet and greet,
I was late for the draft.
Because I was captain.
And I was, like, what the fuck?
So I got, like, messages pinging me, being, like, oh, you're supposed to... you're supposed to do, like, the draft right now.
They're all waiting for you.
And I was, like, WT... I was, like, what the fuck?
Like, a question mark?
What do you mean I'm captain?
Like, I didn't know that.
Because they're, like, yeah, if you see the draft channel, that means you're captain.
And I was, like, I don't pay attention to that.
Like, I don't pay attention to that.
No one told me anything.
I don't pay attention to that.
I usually look at the Twitch Rivals server when, uh, when the stream's about to start.
Um, so then I do that.
I do the drafting.
And then, um...
And I played one quick...
I wanted to do one quick Apex match and then chill until the stream.
And then that Apex match ended up making me champion.
So I had to play 20 minutes of that.
Finish it.
20 minutes of that.
Even though I was, like, WKing everything.
Dying non-stop.
Like, my team kept being alive.
And then after that, I went to the stream.
So, like, literally, no breaks in between.
So I'm gonna take a 30 minute break.
Until the...
Until the next stream.
So I don't...
So I can rest my brain a little bit.
Um, but yes.
I'll pin that in...
I'll pin that on the YouTube waiting room.
But anyway, if you're new here, um...
Thank you everybody for coming.
I usually stream on the YouTube.
So please check me out there.
Please follow me there.
Subscribe to me there.
Um, exclamation point YouTube or socials.
Um, also if you want to, uh, uh, follow me on Twitter.
I usually announce when I'm on Twitch.
When I'm streaming on Twitch.
So please follow me on Twitter.
Um, if you want to support me via other means, uh, please check out my merch.
Uh, Doki, uh, I think it's, like, exclamation point merch.
There's, uh, merch to support me by.
And thank you all for the subscriptions, um, for the subs, for the get the subs, for the donations, for the biddies, for the follows.
I really, really do appreciate for all the raids, as always, everybody.
I'm gonna head off now.
As always, stay hydrated, pause the chat, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, you can stay up a little longer for my second stream of the day.
Alright, I'll see you guys later, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!